so da bin ich ja ich habe was kleines vorn ich dachte mir nachdem wir das in
pyson machen müssen weil es die einzige programmier sprache ist in der das geht
dann ist auch mal wieder guter zeitpunkt sich damit zu beschäftigen
hat mal kurz mein licht hier umstellen ist ein bisschen kacke
wo ist es ist meine lampe sogar aus ane hier decke
80 prozent leid hälscht helligkeit ist viel besser
wir haben irgendwo eine liste aber ich glaube die habe ich die die liste habe ich gar nicht
mehr hier ich meine wir könnten jetzt einfach mal in meine skillliste von meiner bewerbung
gucken und da steht zeugs drinne da steht na gut das ist alles ziemlich ziemlich wir
und durcheinander das steht drinne dass ich sie schab kann das steht dass ich
best and shell scripting kann dass ich rruby kann
musik wird zu laut
das steht drin dass ich ein bisschen was richtig ist aber ich mache da zu wenig mit
java script go zu ja gut ein bisschen aufgetragen schon ein bisschen was die ja
ich kann es lesen ja das stimmt schon p.h.p. groovy sql node gs jetzt geht es mit den
frameworks weiter keine ahnung übelst übelster random kram die die liste die ich da gebaut
habe für meine bewerbung was kriege ich gut hin also ich kriege auf jeden fall sich
ab dort net ganz gut hin ruby kriege ich gut hin java script kriege ich mittlerweile auch
gut hin cobalt hat man ja gesehen ich bin absolut cobalt checker aber vor zwei jahren
an weihnachten gesehen
das meiste kann ich ohne probleme lesen go habe ich schon einiges mitgemacht c plus plus
not gedrungen weil microcontroller ja man kommt da relativ schnell rein aber was ich
immer ganz interessant finde ist so so die feinheiten wie man was macht ich meine man
kann natürlich heißen wie sie scharp benutzen oder umgedreht so vom style her aber das ist
ja meistens nicht sinn und zweck der sache also die kniffe lernt man eigentlich nur wenn
man es benutzt warum kein cobalt ja viel spaß das in cobalt zu machen heute ich zeige euch
ich zeige euch gleich ich mache mal kurz ein update warte mal kennst du chain law fragt
zu ja aber mal chat gpt gefragt aber mal kurz update meinst du es ist wichtiger achso ich
sehe gerade ich bin doch auf just chatting aber komm ich habe it der vops computer technik
programmieren entwickeln deutsch eingestellt als text reicht meinst du es ist wichtiger
viele sprachen zu können oder allgemein sehr ordentlich ich bin ja der ordentlichste programmiere
überhaupt ja japan naja also viele sprachen können jetzt einfach nur mal gesehen haben
weiß ich nicht ob das so viel bringt ich mein gerade so die mainstream sprachen das ist
alles relativ ähnlich muss dann ein bisschen abgedrehter wird ist wenn es zum beispiel
so ein bisschen in richtung funktionale sprachen geht dann ist natürlich schon brainfuck angesagt
aber wenn du so keine ahnung wenn du jetzt was nehmen wir mal sagen wir mal du kannst
ganz gut java du hast ein bisschen bisschen javascript im browser schon gemacht und hast
ich da überall mal umgeguckt du kriegst alles doch eigentlich halbwegs schnell hin wichtiger
ist eigentlich eher dass man erkennt so welche tutorials taugen was dass man das irgendwie
halbwegs einschätzen kann wo man sich eben dann angucken kann also weniger jetzt weniger
dass man das alles schon weiß ja es wird auch auf stack overflow steht viel blödsinn
auch tutorials gibt es viel mist auch youtube videos gibt viel mist dass man irgendwie ganz
gut einschätzen kann ok welche quelle nehme ich da jetzt taugt das was und dann gucke
ich mir das an im ernst also wenn du halbwegs halbwegs durchblick hast dann kannst du dir
eine neue sprache relativ schnell angucken ich meine jetzt nicht jetzt nicht unbedingt
dass du sagst ich setze mir mal nachmittag hin das reicht so für die basics oder kriegst
du so ein paar dinge hin aber du brauchst halt meistens noch so diese das ökosystem
drum herum so eine sprache allein bringt es dir ja nicht du musst zumindest mal die standard
library halbwegs lernen und wissen was da sache ist dazu wäre es vielleicht auch nicht
verkehrt wenn du weißt wieso die wie soll man das nennen so die die allgemeinen vorgaben
sind also wie wie macht man was in welchen sprachen also sprich wie sind so die die allgemein
anerkannten wege gibt gibt ja durchaus unterschiede ja zum beispiel zum beispiel in z sharp ist
es gang und gäbe dass wenn man eine liste hat und möchte dort sagen wir mal nur zahlen
rausfiltern die größer fünf sind dann machst du einfach ein link expression wer dahinter
und gutes go sagt zum beispiel nee nee nee nee nee so zeug machen wir nicht mach für
alles eine schleife also sie haben ja schon unterschiedliche vorstellungen wie man was
macht fängt ja schon bei ganz elementaren sachen an zum beispiel ob man standardmäßig
die klammer auf der gleichen zeile macht wie das if oder unten drunter so das geht
in ganz vielen sprachen wie man will aber es ist von sprache zu sprache unterschiedlich
was so als standard irgendwie akzeptiert ist zum beispiel in go nicht kaut mir alle
haben ich mich studio code hier gar nicht drauf null ja doch kann sein mach mal kurz
ich mach mal kurz update dann starte ich dann starte ich die kiste neu yes yes yes yes
mach einfach mach so also was wollte ich jetzt zeigen ja update aber ich habe ich
gerade gefragt was zum fall ist das da vier champ kann ich ja irgendwie mal einen leeren
ordner aufmachen please also das hat zum beispiel die lautstärke geht mir echt auf den kicks
die können sich wieder nicht entscheiden ob die musik laut oder leise sein soll was entspannenderes
hier viel besser so also du hast ja du hast ja manche sprachen da sagst du dann hier keiner
if eins gleich gleich eins und machst dann so das gibt dann hast du welche die möchten
das also gehen tut das in den allermeisten sprachen egal wie du es machst aber es gibt
so ein paar standard formatierung die sich bei manchen sprachen durchgesetzt haben also
in dort net beispielsweise in c-sharp ist das standard eher so dass du die öffnende
klammer auf die nächste zeile machst in go ist es so in die in go sind die ganz abgedreht
in go machen sie nicht nur die klammer auf die gleiche zeile sondern wenn sie einen ls
haben dann machen sie das so ich muss jetzt sagen ich finde das sieht abartig hässlich
aus aber das ist so wie sich das die leute bei go vorstellen und so wie das die go formatierung
dir auch standardmäßig macht ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ich glaube sogar es ist ich
glaube es ist sogar ein fehler in go wenn du es nicht so machst ich glaube in go kompiliert
gar nicht wenn du es nicht so machst zumal es in go sich die frage nicht stellt weil
der standard code formatter macht dir das schon so wie macht man das sonst also in dort net
umfeld ist es eigentlich eher ups dort net umfeld ist eigentlich eher so die schreibweise
verbreitet
also das ist das so und das sind halt so unterschiede das reicht nicht wenn du eine sprache dir
ein bisschen anguckst sondern man muss halt auch gucken wieso sich die standards da etabliert
haben zum beispiel in in c-sharp würdest du eine liste machen wir tun jetzt einfach mal
so als als wäre das hier eine liste mit 123456 drinne also das ist quasi das ist quasi ein
array mit 12345 drinne so du willst jetzt sagen du willst jetzt alles alles rausfiltern was
größer als drei ist so da würdest du in dort net würdest du sagen select äh nicht
select kratsch würdest du sagen wer was weiß ich i i größer drei oder so dann kriegste
kriegste alles kriegste vier und fünf raus in go in go müsstest du deine vorschleife
machen dafür und solche sachen also bisschen mit der standard library muss man sich auseinandersetzen
und so ein bisschen sich anschauen wie was hat sich so standardmäßig etabliert und
dann kommt man meistens relativ schnell rein
wettel dankeschön für den sub 43 monat extrem poggers
zum thema link so lustige story ich spiele ja ich spiele ja ein bisschen mmo kreisel
trind mit ein paar leuten schon schon wieder seit ein paar monaten und wir haben eine dabei
die heißt lim und irgendwie fragt mich nicht warum immer wenn ich den name schreibe schreibe
ich link zu viel dort netze euch am start das trinkerts einfach übelst wenn ich irgendwas
schreibe link ja ich weiß ja schon hat schon gewisse ähnlichkeiten und so ein h und ein
q ist jetzt auch nicht so unterschiedlich
ja ok ich zeige euch mal was was ich machen will und zwar hat jetzt geupdatet ok hat geupdatet
die reboot mal kurz ich glaube da noch kernel update gemacht und alles schadet auf jeden
fall nichts zu rebooten
heute habt ihr schon mal wenn toll benutzt was sorry was ganz was anderes jetzt weiß
hat es ist jetzt relativ random
also ich meine ich kenne das mal kurz
wenn toll ich meine das da damit kann man usb sticks erstellen multiboot usb weiß nicht
zwangsläufig usb sticks sind aber multiboot laufwerke also mit der regel sind usb sticks
du formatierst das ding bzw lässt das lässt das von wenn toll einrichten und dann hast
du den ordner da ziehst du alle isos rein und dann hast du wenn du wenn du rechner davon
startest kann man ins boot menü gehen und dort auswählen was man von seinen isos starten
ist eigentlich eine ganz coole sache aber worauf ich worauf ich raus will also ich habe mir
auch einen usb stick in den boot stick kann ich euch kann ich euch ja eigentlich mal komm
kurz bevor wir bevor wir anfangen hab da mal ich hab da mal eine frage vielleicht vielleicht
weiß das ja einer von euch ich mache mal kurz ich mache mal kurz den usb stick rein
so blum blum blum was auf den keks man will einfach nur den innerwillig connect
so jetzt gehen wir mal in die vm zum glück habe ich neu gestartet jetzt funktioniert
ja sdb so ich muss ja neu starten und jetzt mal kurz escape escape hämmern und jetzt
geklappt so usb device so jetzt kriegste jetzt kriegste dann usb stick du hast doch auf twitter
was wegen iso ja richtig richtig so also ich habe jetzt alle mögliche ich habe jetzt immer
die sachen die man eventuell brauchen könnte da auf den usb stick hauen also sprich ich
habe nkali linux intelligent rescue system rescue cd netboot so jetzt ist die große preisfrage
kann das ding windows booten ordentlich also was man theoretisch machen könnte ist ich
könnte netboot verwenden also gehen wir mal netboot rein also für alles für alles was
ich nicht auf dem usb stick habe und booten will und ein netzwerk habe kann ich über netboot
gehen das ist kein problem so also ich könnte jetzt über netboot gehen und sagen windows
das ding ist bloß funktioniert nicht wirklich dazu brauchst du in lokalen samba server mit
entpackte windows iso und und ganz komischem zeug drauf also nix nix was man eigentlich
haben will und ich habe jetzt gedacht vielleicht gibt es vielleicht gibt es die möglichkeit
dass man hier in windows setup rein macht jetzt weiß ich nicht das ist das ding ich weil
wir können es mal schnell ausprobieren theoretisch bevor wir anfangen zu was wir können es theoretisch
mal ausprobieren also ich habe jetzt die wichtigsten sachen drauf also also ich habe es im prinzip
so gemacht ich habe ein eventuell usb stick gemacht wo die ganzen isos drauf sind und
ein zweites zweites laufwerk also zweite partition mit 400 gig wo ich dann irgendwie daten drauf
speichern kann die ich vielleicht irgendwie retten will oder so ich meine wir können das
mit der windows iso einfach mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert ich kann ja ich kann ja
schnell mal den windows iso runterladen ja windows plus pxe ist abfuck ist komplett komplett
abfuck deswegen will ich habe ich ja gedacht vielleicht weiß dass einer von euch iso list
so steht da windows drinnen windows ok testet us series windows 11 und dann dann probieren
wir das mal aus bento bento net distros moment der gibt es aber keine gibt es aber kein download
ok das das funktioniert also windows 11 englisch x6 iso und dann auf geht's das probiere ich
jetzt mal schnell aus bevor wir anfangen windows 11 iso download wo gibt es denn so was kann
man darf man darf man noch ganz quatsch welchen teamwork starten brauche ich da überhaupt
nicht mehr fdisk minus l def sdb mount def sdb 1 mnt da haben jetzt die isos drauf erstellen
von installationsmedien multi edition iso ja ja herunterladen ist gut produktsprache
arabisch ich will englisch international ja perfekt ja probieren wirs doch probieren
wirs doch einfach mal ausspannen oh die microsoft was ist denn mit euch los guck mal hier das
flutscht ja mal richtig 48 mb die sekunde da wird gesaugt gatschi bass die game haben
die iso von windows 11 aber nicht von windows 10 lul by the way was wir schon mal machen
können ist bevor damit wir klar anfangen können mal ach mal ich hab ja schon ein bisschen
professionen leute nicht irgendwie die ganze die nicht nicht für die kacknubs professionell
also heute ist professioner professionell python entwicklung stream angesagt nicht community
oder sowas wie die ganzen geringverdiener professionell ok also haben wir jetzt die
iso runtergeladen habe ich noch nicht einmal gestartet ich habe so letztens installiert
weil ich mir gedacht habe warum habe ich eigentlich immer die community version installiert wenn
ich doch ein all desktop package von den seit ein paar jahren habe also angeblich kann wenn
der secure boot seit ein paar versionen out of the box und soll soll immer funktionieren
so weit so gut was wird dann später mit python gemacht ok erzähl ich dir übrigens leute
wir müssen mal kurz unsere unsere modge unseren python modge huldigen ich habe nämlich letztens
was gesehen auf reddit das weiß er nicht dass ich das gesehen habe aber ich habe es letztens
gesehen und zwar ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob es noch auf der seite steht so reddit
self hosted also wenn ihr daheim irgendwas betreibt ist das wirklich ein nicer sub reddit
um so mal bisschen durchzugucken was aktuell angesagt ist reddit soll mir keine notifications
posten so und da gab es letztens einen post und ich weiß nicht wie der titel war irgendwas
mit show und da habe ich mir gedacht als ich gesehen habe von wem das da ist nicht mehr
drauf dann habe ich mir gedacht als ich gesehen habe von wem das ist da dachte ich mir so
der name kommt mir aber irgendwie bekannt vor reidach gesehen kann doch nicht so weit
her sein hallo warum steht es hier nicht drin und das muss man das sagen ist es nicht hot
ist nicht hot mods mods not hot
kommt mal letztens bin ich auf freitag bin ich auf auf reddit gegangen und habe auf einmal
gesehen aha out and rewritten in go und da gucke ich mir so den name hier oben an und
ich denke mir so irgendwie kommt dir der kerl bekannt vor
tja können wir an der stelle mal werbung für sein projekt machen also unser mega five
mod hat ein wake on lan gui gebaut jetzt anscheinend in der dritten version und jetzt ist es
rewritten in go jetzt ist es gut version 4 ist wahrscheinlich dann rewritten in rust
das ist zumindest das mindeste was man erwarten kann denke ich so und wer mehrere rechner
über wake on lan aufwecken will er hat übrigens auch eine sehr schöne readme gebaut kann
dieses gui hier verwenden guckt da könnt ihr euch könnt ihr euch eure ganzen lokalen
kisten rein stellen und dann kann man auf den knopf drücken dann sendet er einen wake
on lan package mod get time
github sterne gehen durch die decke massive stonks ich glaube der fiat champ braucht auch
mal den artikel aber da ist poggers ist ein richtiger sixhead mod gut haben wir das gucken
wir ob die windows easy jetzt runter die windows easy runtergeladen ist ja ach so ich zeige
ihr mein ich zeige dir mal was für den dann dann beantworte ich mal den chat ich zeige
ich erzähle mal ich erzähle euch mal kurz was wir heute im stream machen bevor wir das
mit bevor ich den chat schnell durchgehe und bevor ich die das mit der iso ausprobieren
und zwar ich will mir also erstens will ich ein bisschen pausen üben und zwar ich hätte
gern einen timer hier oben eine stoppuhr auf meiner wie heißt das notification auf meiner
status leiste und es gibt keine richtige stoppuhr das einzige was es gibt ist kann euch das
mal zeigen das einzige was es da als plug-in gibt ist so ein timer das ist aber ein timer
der ist für arbeitszeit und dann pause machen gedacht das ist kein timer wo du einstellen
kannst auf 15 minuten und dann wird und dann blinkt und gibt eine notification und ich
habe jetzt schon öfter festgestellt ich fände es sehr praktisch wenn ich in ganz stink normalen
stoppuhr beziehungsweise so einen alarm timer hätte für meine status leiste und nachdem
diese status leiste dieses projekt komplett pausen programmiertes dachte ich mir wir bauen
uns mal sowas selbst ja voll ab und können dabei was sinnvolles machen und ein bisschen
pausen üben das machen wir natürlich natürlich ein bisschen so dass man mit maus hoch maus
runter den timer einstellen kann und notification übergeben kann aber hauptsächlich hauptsächlich
um ein bisschen pausen zu üben so jetzt kopieren wir das mal drauf und gucken ob es funktioniert
cp home max downloads windows elf iso das kopiert man jetzt einfach rein wenn toi windows elf
anscheinend anscheinend einfach runterladen und drauf kopieren das test wird schnell muss
mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert und dann fangen wir an ein bisschen progas stell zu
machen okay geupdatet hat alles wunderbar wir können schon mal aufmachen und also eins
muss man ja sagen die default settings und sowas was java angeht font rendering und alles
ist wirklich übelste abfack zum glück haben die das hier gescheit gemacht wenn der initiale
dialog weg ist so alles okay ist kopiert unmount mnt jetzt hängt es weil erstmal der usb stick
cache geflascht werden muss geflascht werden muss geflascht werden muss auf den flash
dazwischenzeit kann ich kann ich ja ein bisschen chat angucken gar keins das das für diese
status leiste so wie man da widgets für diese status leiste baut muss ich gucken kannst
du mal erläutern was du für eine distro nutzt also auf desktop windows auf dem anderen ja
hast du auch gerade gesehen guck da hier da da linux da windows das funktioniert folgendermaßen
ich benutze mehrere desstops unter windows das hier ist desktop eins das hier ist desktop
zwei und in desktop zwei ist vor allem ein workstation im fullscreen und ich habe es
eingestellt dass diese hässliche leiste hier standardmäßig wenn man nicht irgendwie
nix macht nicht nicht da ist kuck die verschwindet wenn man da nicht extra extra tasten drückt
so und was ich jetzt mache ist ich drücke jetzt wenn ich in der vm bin die tastenkombination
für desktop switchen und wenn ich in windows bin die tastenkombination für desktop switchen
und dann kann ich wechseln zwischen fullscreen vm und meiner windows kiste natürlich hast
du ein paar beschränkungen dadurch wenn du es in der vm laufen lässt also spiele musst
du gar nicht probieren bis ein bisschen ältere funktionieren aber spielen in der vm ist nicht
schön das einzige wo man spielen kann in der vm ist vielleicht mit kvm und gpu passt
zu oder sowas aber in dieser in dieser vm willst du nicht wirklich ich will es nicht
wirklich spielen ich glaube das grafisch intensivste was ich hier drin ausführen kann ist glx
gears oder so das war es dann wieder schon ja ich glaube viel grafisch intensiver geht
es in der vm nicht hat man wie viel fps haben wir dann bei gehr konnte glx gears nicht die
fps anzeigen ach minus info wow wow wow nee nee nee es ist nicht es ist eh wie sync an
dann bringt es bringt es wahrscheinlich eh nicht also das war wahrscheinlich das aufwendigste
was ich machen kann ist auch sinnvoll also bevor du jetzt dualboot machst weil dualboot
ist richtig nervig oder bevor du jetzt ins kalte wasser springst und komplett linux drauf
haust ist die vm das beste was du machen kannst und für ein player kostet nix oder du kannst
auf virtualbox nehmen oder du kaufst dir bei einem reseller für drei euro 50 in den vm
bei workstation key das geht natürlich auch warum jetzt bei unter die data analysis gegangen
nehmen kann damit auch andere sachen machen ja hat man gerade schon
warum nicht dualboot das hat gar keinen technischen kund dualboot funktioniert gut vielleicht
hast du mit vielleicht hast du mit cq boot und gedöns ein bisschen problem aber dualboot
funktioniert prinzipiell dualboot ist einfach nervig du brauchst bestimmt drei vier minuten
sagen wir so zwei drei minuten bis du in dem anderen betriebssystem drinne bist und du
kannst jetzt nicht sagen ich benutze für alles was mit gebastelt zu tun hat mein linux und
wenn ich spiele und videosachen machen will mache ich es unter windows dafür sind die
zwei bis drei minuten einfach zu lang also es ist ein unterschied ob ich jetzt sagen
kann so auf geht's linux so auf geht's windows oder ob ich jetzt erst mal rebooten muss also
das hat keinen technischen grund das ist eher ein nerv factor grund warum ich dualboot nicht
mag das nächste ist viele leute brauchen gerade am anfang wenn sie noch keine große ahnung
von linux haben oftmals ihr windows noch um nachzugucken wie irgendwas geht oder um vielleicht
aber wirklich was wichtiges zu machen wo sie noch nicht wissen wie sie unter linux geht
vielleicht finden sie auch irgendwas was unter linux gar nicht geht zum beispiel apex spielen
oder sowas und das ist natürlich schwierig wenn du nicht nachgucken kannst und dann
müsstest du zu windows booten nachgucken und dann müsstest du zurück zu linux zum ausprobieren
apex geht mittlerweile ja wirklich nice wusste ich nicht ich habe ich habe ewig nicht mehr
versucht so sachen unter linux auszuführen ja da nehmen halt fortnite oder rainbow 6 das
geht garantiert nicht gut gta ist auch voller cheater das wundert mich nicht wie starten
man in die drei eigentlich flat packs keine flat packs ich würde ich würde davon ausgehen
dass du flat pack startest wie überall anders das ding braucht das ding braucht ein auswahl
für alle desktop applications und wenn flat packs in so einem desktop startding wohin
legen dann sollte es gehen ich kann keine ahnung ich verwende keine flasche ich will
es nicht ausschließen dass ich nicht in den flat pack über in den user repo oder sonst
was habe aber kann ich dir nichts zu sagen ich verwende kaum flat pack ich verwende
auch keine snaps oder sonst was ja ich habe ein paar sachen gefunden die unter wsl eklig
sind ich hatte letztens erst wieder irgendwas was war das ich mal gucken ob ich über laufe
des streams drauf komme ich hatte letztens was das hat mich extrem genervt wo ich gerade
das system funktioniert nicht ja gut also es gibt allgemeine sachen dass du zum beispiel
keine dass du keine netzlauferke gescheit mounten kannst und dass du immer noch problem
mit grafischer anwendung hast wobei das wobei das besser ist aber ich hatte letztens was
das war mega nervig vielleicht komme ich irgendwie im lauf des streams noch drauf wo ich wo ich
gesagt habe ah guck mal da sagt das zum d geht nicht das ist richtig nestet virtualisierung
logischerweise ist auch kacke weil es halt eine vm was war das denn ich hatte ich komme
jetzt gerade nicht drauf ich weiß noch letztens habe ich mal wieder nachgedacht siste tut
wieder nicht richtig in wsl ach ja eine andere sache die auch nervig ist wenn man vm verwenden
will für vms plus wsl für windows subsystem das funktioniert nicht gescheit weil da kann
jetzt wsl nichts für muss man aber sagen ja weil wenn du damit damit wsl funktioniert
es ist ja mittlerweile eine vm also wsl 2 ist das aktuelle das support das ist ja unter
der haupe eine hyper wie vm und das beißt sich ein bisschen mit vm workstation offiziell
ist es zwar supportet aber du hast zum beispiel probleme unter linux wenn deine vm mehr als
ein cpu kern hat mit input lag also das ist noch nicht ganz rund da kann wsl nicht nix
für aber du brauchst hyper wie um wsl zu verwenden und mit hyper wie zusammen gehen
dann keine vms mehr gescheit das ist alles etwas sub optimal da spielt bestimmt auch
windows 11 noch mit rein und solche geschichten mann ist es einfach ein bisschen eklig kollege
auf der arbeit hat richtige probleme dass ein gedreh pro abfahrt langsam ist er hat
es irgendwie auf dem windows auf dem windows laufwerk liegen und greift von dort per wsl
drauf zu und das braucht bei jedem kommando 10 sekunden bis was geht kannst du halt absolut
nicht verwenden es könnte auch an unserem viren scanner lokal liegen weiß ja nicht hast
du ein guide für dein setup also einrichtung altes wort ja wir haben vor ein paar glaube
vor zwei wochen haben wir angefangen die kiste einzurichten jetzt ist es fertig meine dort
falls lade ich lade ich noch hoch ich habe das ja alles schon schon fertig müsste ich
eigentlich mal pushen richtige programmierung ja muss ja irgendwann auch mal sein als johi
dankeschön für den sub was ist denn was ist denn nicht was ist denn eine falsche java
vielleicht und c++ die sind zwar keine falschen programmierung aber gerade c++ sagt einfach
nur unglaublich wie läuft es auf der arbeit noch motiviert oder läuft der countdown naja
also ich würde lügen wenn ich sagen würde ich bin wahnsinnig motiviert der countdown
läuft juckt mich juckt mich eigentlich nichts mehr großartig muss jetzt ich muss jetzt
noch ein paar sachen machen bevor ich den neuen job anfangen muss mir mal wieder gültigen
ausweis besorgen ich muss ein führungszeugnis beantragen weil bank und versicherungen und
so die haben halt immer so spezial auflagen ich dann zettel wo drauf steht es liegt nichts
vor ich muss es ja schon mal machen und da muss ein paar sachen ausfüllen ja der countdown
läuft auf jeden fall ich hatte letzte woche mein austrittsgespräch interview und im fragebogen
was fanden sie kacke und ich habe mich ein bisschen darüber ausgelassen was ich kacke
fand also wirklich richtig zur sprache ich ich hatte nicht den eindruck als möchte man
es wirklich wissen die ist da sehr sehr schnell über ein einige punkte drüber geskippt ich
wollte beispielsweise dass wenn es welche wahrscheinlich noch per mail nachträglich
schreiben ich wollte mich zum beispiel auch über management entscheidungen bisschen aufregen
dass das mit dazu beigetragen hat auf der einen seite sagen man soll die fehler in kauf
nehmen und wenn die fehler dann auftreten dann will man das nicht mehr gesagt haben
das ist ja was das regt mich eh allgemein auf das ist was regt mich bei jedem auf aber
natürlich wenn es irgendwelche menager machen noch mehr weil das ist exakt das ist letztendlich
ihr job und den machen sie da nicht also stelle euch mal vor ihr führt irgendwie neues produkt
ein oder ihr sollt ein produkt auswählen ist eigentlich egal was genau übrigens dankeschön
athena für den sub so und dann wird gesagt ok das und das muss so gemacht werden und
wenn fehler auftreten dann nehmen wir die in kauf hauptsache wird so gemacht so dann wird
das so gemacht also wohlgemerkt durchaus mit dem ein oder anderen bedenken dabei dass es
vielleicht dass vielleicht probleme geben könnte ja das wird wird so gemacht und wenn
doch fehler auftreten dann nehmen wir die in kauf und dann geht es eine weile und irgendwann
treten tatsächlich diese fehler auf und damit gesagt was wie konnte man das denn übersehen
dass solche fehler auftreten das geht ja überhaupt nicht dass da fehler auftreten vor allem diese
fehler da will man nichts mehr davon wissen dass man explizit gesagt hat dass man das
in kauf nimmt das sind das sind so sachen die regen mich da schon ein bisschen auf mittlerweile
bin ich halt auch dazu übergegangen so wichtige sachen von denen ich denke dass die eben in
zukunft noch mal relevant werden können die schreibe ich auf wer das wann wo gesagt hat
so wie findest du diese font mal ja die font aus
die font habe ich schon mal gesehen ist es ist es ein paid font oder es ist ein freier
ein kostenloser font okay dann hab ich doch schon mal irgendwo gesehen bin ich eigentlich
ganz schick finde ich eigentlich ganz schick ich muss sagen ich werde wahrscheinlich mein ich
habe früher relativ oft gewechselt weil ich da immer wollte dass beim terminal jeden tag ein
bisschen anders aussieht irgendwie habe ich da habe ich abwechslung gebrauchter aber ich habe
jetzt seit jahren schon den gleichen font hier im terminal und im editor und ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich habe in nächster zeit auch nicht vor zu wechseln ich habe mich da so dran gewöhnt und
ich finde den font auch auch wirklich schön gemacht das ist keine komplette neuentwicklung
das ist eine weiterentwicklung von einem schon bestehenden bestehenden font ich finde den
finden sehr angenehm das ist hack ja genau richtig heckremence ja der ist nice das ist ja keine
neuentwicklung das ist eine weiterentwicklung von irgendwas schon bestehenden font family aber
insgesamt insgesamt ist hack wirklich ein sehr sehr nicer font so wir rebooten jetzt mal schnell
leute und gucken ob das mit ventoy funktioniert und dann machen wir proga proga stels gucken wir
mal ob das mit windows funktioniert bin mal gespannt ok vorher vorher ich ich trau ich trau ich trau
der ganzen sache nicht ich war mal kurz ein snapshot weil nicht das windows mir jetzt mein
linux überschreibt das was welche distro das ist artschlinux by the way aber ist es wirklich
go go habe ich auch schon programmiert ja
hast du tipps für das aufsetzen einer kali vm also ehrlich gesagt und der hyper wie keine ahnung
wie gut da grafische oberflächen unter linux funktionen kali hat xf ce glaube oder irgendwas
irgendwas relativ leichtgewichtig ist oder ne elix de hat hat kali ge irgendwas in der richtung das
läuft in vms eigentlich ganz gut hyper wie keine ahnung virtual box virtual box kannst du mal
probieren in virtual box in den settings den speicher von einer grafikan ein bisschen zu
erhöhen und 3d oder wie heißt es hardware acceleration einzuschalten ansonsten sollte
aber in virtual box das ganze relativ gut funktionieren ist glaube ich nicht empfehlen
tja chat ist artschlinux empfehlenswert für neulinge also ich würde sagen wenn du es als
zweite als zweites system verwendest und wenn du wirklich was lernen willst ist es nicht schlecht
weil du wirst wahrscheinlich erst mal fluchen dabei aber das artsch wiki ist so ziemlich die
beste ressource die es gibt für linux vieles was im artsch wiki steht gilt für alle gilt für
alle distribution nicht nur für artsch und für artsch ist natürlich besonders nützlich dazu
kommt dass die installations die installation zumindest relativ einfach ist mittlerweile mit
dem installer script mit dem installer script kriegt zumindest dass jeder installiert und du kannst es
mittlerweile auch mit basic desktop umgebung installieren aber die finde ich nicht finde ich
nicht schön was gut ist wenn du beispielsweise dich damit beschäftigen willst und du machst
das so wie ich was sie in der vm was sie in der vm und machst hier hast hier dein windows und da
machst du in der artschlinux vm da kannst du dir das nämlich an du kannst mich aus snapshots machen
wenn irgendwas kaputt geht und so was und dann machst du meine installation und guckst ob du
schaffst irgendwie den desktop zum laufen zu bekommen also wenn du schaffst in artschlinux zu
installieren darauf desktop zum laufen zu bekommen und so das copy und paste in und aus der vm
funktioniert da hast du wahrscheinlich mehr gelernt als die meisten azubis in drei jahren
ausbildung aus linux angehen ja kann jeder machen wie er will ich finde den installer
eigentlich ganz praktisch gerade wenn man neu ist ich verwende den installer übrigens auch
also ich finde den also den neuen artsch installer wer ist das artsch setup oder artsch install ist wunderbar dauert
eigentlich nur eine viertel stunde so also jetzt mal gucken ob das mal gucken ok windows iso ist
schon mal drinnen meint ihr das funktioniert jetzt dass man den windows iso davon starten kann
boot in ww mode da stand irgendwas von ww das funktioniert einfach
das geht das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass es funktioniert ein moment noch ist es nicht
gestartet post jam noch ist es nicht gestartet das heißt ja nichts dass es funktioniert
macht es jetzt noch was
das macht nichts mehr oder ein usb stick hat leider auch kein keine led oder so ich sehe
nicht ob da drauf zugegriffen wird einmal kurz abwarten was ist was ist neben artsch
noch beliebt ubuntu ja kannst du eigentlich nicht viel verkehrt machen mint mint oder
ubuntu kannst du beides nehmen ist ist vollkommen in ordnung ja würde ich also ich persönlich
würde auf dem desktop wahrscheinlich eher zu mint greifen und dann mit mate wenn es
was fertiges sein soll ich mag zwar keine lilox desktop aber wenn es ein echter desktop
sein muss der so ganz klassisch desktop mir sie ist dann ist mir noch am liebsten ansonsten
ihr kennt mich ich habe eigentlich gar keine desktop environments laufen leute das funktioniert
einfach das lädt den windows installer vom usb stick das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht
dass das funktioniert sehr sehr pogu nice ok gut da wir das jetzt ausprobiert da kann
ich jetzt auch neu starten und den usb stick raus machen blub blub blub blub blub blub
blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub
blub blub blub blub blub blub blub bus
mx linux immer noch verwende das seriously jemand
Ich habe mir das mal angeguckt mir hat das überhaupt nicht gefallen
Ich kann also ich kann nicht verstehen dass das auf platz eins ist ich habe wirklich meine wirklich fragwürdig wie
Wie aussagekräftig diese diese liste hier ist
Also Endeavor os ist ganz ok das ist quasi arch based mit verschiedenen vorkonfigurierten desktops das heißt wenn jemanden arch haben will ist das gar nicht so übel
Mint ist nice manjaro kann man auch nehmen wenn man was jetzt ich weiß jetzt regnet sich die leute auch auch auf aber wenn man was arch based haben will kann man auch manjaro nehmen
Wobei manjaro halt so zwischen repos hat und sie sich in letzten paar jahren
mit einigen dingern
nicht so nicht so glückliches händchen bewiesen haben so mit zertifikaten die ablaufen und
Als noch chrome kodex und komische dinger komische dinger
Pop os hatte ich mir auch mal angeguckt verstehe ich auch nicht warum man das verwendet fedora seriously leute
Wir haben auf der arbeit fast ausschließlich red hat wobei man sagen muss cento s und
In zukunft gibt es ja kein cento s in der klassischen variante mehr
Aber also ich benutze viel ich benutze viel rpm basiertes und ich mag es auf dem desktop überhaupt nicht
Ich mag weder red hat
oder oder fedora auf dem desktop noch mag ich suze auf dem desktop
Also was red hat beziehungsweise rpm basiertes kommt mir nicht auf den desktop drauf
Ubuntu geht vollkommen in ordnung als desktop desktop distribution debian im prinzip auch wenn man auf bisschen ältere sachen
Steht dann ist es kein problem
Leid sagt mir nix garuda ist gerade relativ angesagt sorry und hat schon mal angeguckt war auch nichts open suze all da gehen wir bloß weg
elementary ist für alle die mac os mögen ganz nice die
Linux wollen was aussieht wie mech oder ein bisschen wie mech
Dann können die leute elementary verwenden
Alma ist glaube ich das neue in der neue red hat nachbau kali gut kennt man
es ist halt bisschen obskura
Doktor pro clubs länglich für den sapp
Ja
Taking pictures kann das also
Tja...
Mein Linux hat doch auch...
...irgendwas grafisch. Warum ich mit Syslinux boote?
Ich boote mit dem, was standardmäßig der Installer draufhaut.
Das ist glaub ich ein System-D-Boot und...
...Zeug. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Mein Linux hat auch was grafisches.
Naja...
Mein Linux hat...
Erstmal ein...
...super Hintergrund. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Desktop-Background. Aber es ist kein Desktop, weil du siehst...
...ich kann hier auf dem Desktop nix klicken.
Kein rechts, links klicken. Ich kann nix markieren.
Nee, wir haben doch gar nicht angefangen, Random Win.
Macht ihr keine Gedanken. Du hast nix verpasst.
Ähm...
Also ich hab keinen Desktop.
Ich hab nur den Hintergrund. Es ist kein Desktop.
Das Einzige, was ich habe und das Einzige, was dieses grafische...
...diese grafische Oberfläche kann, ist...
...Fenster...
...im Fullscreen anzeigen.
Beziehungsweise Fenster...
Es sind ja noch nicht mal Fenster.
Ja, Anwendung im Fullscreen.
Anwendung im Fullscreen.
Benutzen und zwischen verschiedenen Arbeitsflächen umschalten.
Fertig.
Mehr kann das nicht.
Ich mein, theoretisch kann es Fenster.
Ja.
Wenn ich wirklich will...
...könnte ich...
...könnte ich so eine Art Fenster...
...Fenster gedürnt sein. Aber warum? Warum?
Warum soll man das wollen? Ja.
Du kannst ja mal den neuesten Desktop-Manager...
...von PopOS Written in Rust ausprobieren.
Okay.
PopOS...
...Desktop...
...Written in Rust. Ja.
Das ist gut. Da kann man ein bisschen...
...lustig drüber machen. Über die Rust.
Die Rust Task Force...
...auf Hacker News.
Hab ich verschrieben?
PopOS.
PopOS!
Nee, das funktioniert nicht gescheit. Du brauchst ja schon ne Maus.
Du brauchst ja schon ne Maus. Also einfach nur Terminal ist nichts.
Du hast ne kacke Auflösung.
Aber wenn man die hochtränken kann, du brauchst ja schon ne Maus...
...zum Anklicken für einiges. Gerade für den Webbrowser.
Kennst du Zscaler?
Ich kenn Zscaler als Upscaling...
...als Upscaling Algorithmus in FFmpeg.
Aber ich glaube nicht...
...Up- und Downscaling Algorithmus in FFmpeg.
Aber...
...ich glaube nicht, dass du das meinst.
Was ist das Keyword? Was muss man...
Bei was?
Für was?
West Term ist mega nice.
Was heißt das war ein guter Tipp?
Ich glaube, das haben wir einfach mal ausprobiert.
Ich fand's am Anfang kacke.
Und hab nach Viertelstunde festgestellt...
...dass es eigentlich doch geil.
Gut ist.
Ist das nicht ein VPN-Klein? Kann sein.
So, also, haben wir das?
Gut, dann können wir mal anfangen.
Also ich versuch das mal noch kurz zusammenfassen...
...was ich heute vorhab.
Wie gut das klappt...
...muss ich noch zeigen.
Und zwar folgendes.
Ihr seht doch hier oben...
Ich mein wir könnten die Leiste jetzt zum Üben...
...ein bisschen größer machen.
Ihr seht ja hier oben meine Statusleiste.
Und was ich gerne in meiner Statusleiste hätte ist...
...einen Timer.
Einen stinknormalen Countdown Timer.
Den ich einstellen kann auf...
...keine Ahnung...
...520.
Und dann klicke ich drauf.
Und wenn ich nochmal drauf klicke...
...dann pausiert er.
Und wenn ich wieder drauf klicke...
...dann macht er weiter.
Und wenn er bei Null ist, blinkt er rot.
Oder zeigt den Hintergrund rot an.
Oder so was.
Und schickt vielleicht den Notification oder so.
Dann schickt nochmal einen Timer.
Mehr...
...brauche ich gar nicht.
Tetscaler ist eine Zero Trust Network Lösung.
Aha.
Habe ich noch nichts von gehört.
Wahrscheinlich weil es was...
Wobei, nee, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich habe das gerade verwechselt.
Ist das Java oder JavaScript?
Weil...
...es gibt ja irgendwelche...
...Scripting Test Frameworks in JavaScript...
...die man heute nicht mal verwendet.
Die richtig gesagt haben müssen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist eigentlich gerade in JavaScript angesagt?
Oder irgendwie sowas wahrscheinlich.
Java, ja dann liegt es wahrscheinlich daran...
...das was mit Java zu tun hat.
Warum hast du das angeheftet?
Oder habe ich das angeheftet? Nee.
Irgendjemand, der Captain Panger hat das angeheftet.
Jest, ja Jest kenne ich.
Aber Skript.
So, also, fangen wir mal an.
Ich bin gerade mit meinem Stuhl über das Kabel gefahren.
Re-Hat-Time.
So, also, man kann...
...man kann ganz gut nachgucken...
...wie die Plugins funktionieren.
Das ist nämlich wirklich ganz gut aufgebaut.
Ich zeige euch das mal.
Also das Projekt für diese Statusleiste hier oben...
...also das da nicht, also für die Statusleiste hier...
...das nennt sich Bumblebee Status.
Vorher hatte ich E3 Status Rust.
Es gibt ja noch viel mehr.
Es gibt ja noch Polybar.
Polybar ist für die Leute...
...die es extrem übertreiben wollen.
Und da gibt es noch...
...wie heißt das andere...
...wo du komplett eigene Widgets designen kannst?
EEW?
Widgets oder sowas?
Nee, EWW.
So rum.
Da kannst du dir komplett eigene Widgets...
...für dein Desktop designen.
Komplett, komplett overkill.
Mir reicht das.
Ich hab ne Anzeige ob mein Clipboard...
...ein und ausgeschaltet ist.
Clipboard ein und ausschalten...
...ist tatsächlich gar nicht mal so unwichtig.
Stellt euch mal vor...
...ich will ein Passwort kopieren.
Ich kopiere jetzt ein super geheimes Passwort...
...mal von meinem zweiten Rechner aus.
Und fügt es jetzt hier ein...
...so dass ich es nicht sehe. Und guck...
...im Clipboard Manager...
Was?
Hab ich da irgendjemand...
...angeklickt...
...im Chat und der Name ist jetzt irgendwie...
...eine Frage, was auch immer.
Das muss irgendwas aus dem Twitch Chat sein...
...ich hab keine Ahnung was das ist.
Zumindest wenn mein...
...Clipboard Manager an ist...
...dann seht ihr jetzt das Passwort wenn ich da reingucke.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Jetzt habt ihr mein super secures Passwort gesehen...
...obwohl ich das nicht will.
Das heißt ich kann jetzt auch...
...einfach mal mein Clipboard...
...ausschalten. Und wenn ich jetzt ein weiteres...
...super geheimes Passwort kopiere...
...dann...
...seht ihr es nicht.
Obwohl es in dem Clipboard ist. Guck...
...es ist im Clipboard. Super secret Passwort.
Aber ihr seht es nicht.
Ich kann Clipboard eins ausschalten.
Das ist für mich beim Streaming ganz praktisch.
Ich sehe ob ich NumLog ein oder aus habe.
Ich sehe die Load von meinem System.
Ich sehe die RAM Auslastung, Disk Auslastung...
...und die CPU Auslastung.
Mehr brauche ich nicht. Das einzige was ich...
...wirklich noch ganz gerne hätte ist...
...den Timer.
Das fände ich sehr praktisch.
Irgendwas wo ich draufklicken kann...
...was ich auf 5 Minuten einstellen kann.
Beispielsweise ich habe irgendwo das Fenster...
...aufgemacht und will in 3 Minuten...
...nicht vergessen dran zu denken.
Timer klicke ich drauf. 3 Minuten das...
...klingt rot und wenn es nach 3 Minuten rot...
...plinkt weiß ich ja, Mist, ich muss Fenster...
...zumachen. Und wie gesagt...
...diese Statusleiste, das Projekt...
...was diese Statusleiste bereitstellt...
...ist komplett in Python programmiert.
Ging das nicht, dass du hattest?
Was meinste?
Achso, nee, der war Mist dafür.
Der hat sich auch immer selbst resettet...
...und er hat mich angezeigt wenn er abgelaufen ist...
...und vor allem konntest du die Zeit...
...nicht einstellen, dynamisch.
Machst du das mit dem Messenger-Dienst?
Nee, mach ich nicht. Mit dem Clipboard...
...guck ich einfach ob mein Clipboard-Manager...
...läuft oder nicht.
Wenn der Clipboard-Manager nicht läuft...
...dann wird das als geblockt angesehen.
Was hab ich da denn?
Ist das irgendein Passwort...
...was ich irgendwo mal eingetippt hab?
Keiner.
Egal.
Gut.
Ach, wisst ihr was das gewesen sein konnte...
...vom letzten Mal?
Wobei zwischendrin...
...da hab ich bestimmt irgendwas aus dem Chat.
Chatcopypasted gerade, keine Ahnung.
So.
Jetzt will ich mir angucken...
...wie man das macht. Übrigens, das Projekt...
...an sich ist wirklich cool.
Wer so eine simple Status-Leiste braucht...
...die jede Menge Sachen kann...
...sollte sich das mal angucken.
Du kannst CPU anzeigen...
...Datum anzeigen, Disk-Auslastung...
...Git Branches anzeigen lassen...
...Keypresses anzeigen, Layouts...
...Tastaturbelegung anzeigen lassen...
...Arbeitsspeicher-Auslastung...
...Netzwerkauslastung...
...kannst Sachen pingen. Also das ist ein...
...wirklich nicees Projekt.
Wie gesagt, ich hätte einen normalen Timer gerne.
Das ist nichts super Komplexes, ja.
Das ist aber für mich ganz gut...
...weil ich jetzt nicht der Ultra-Python-Checker bin.
Deswegen dachte ich mir...
...dass es was Gutes ist, was wir mal...
...ausprobieren können zusammen.
So, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal angucken...
...wie man solche Module entwickelt.
Also was ich bei dem...
...Kern auf der Webseite gesehen hab, ist...
...Developer's Guide...
...How to Write a Module.
An sich ist es...
...relativ einfach.
Entweder...
...macht man das...
...im Projektverzeichnis...
...falls man ein Pull-Request machen will...
...bei dem Off-Git-Tab.
Oder, wenn man es lokal testen will...
...legt man das neue Modul...
...einfach hier drunter ab.
Also machen wir mal ein Ordner...
...und gehen mal in den Ordner rein...
...und legen dort was an und gucken...
...dann ob das funktioniert.
Touch, wie heißt das?
Alert, Punkt...
...muss man das Punkt Pi nennen oder nicht?
Ich nenn's mal Punkt Pi.
So, und jetzt tragen wir mal unser neues Widget...
...Alert in hier drinnen ein...
...und gucken was passiert.
Nix.
Okay, naja gut.
Das wundert mich jetzt nicht, dass da nichts passiert...
...außer ein komischer Fehler, weil...
...in der Datei steht ja auch nix drinnen.
Dann öffnen wir das mal...
...hier drinnen...
...und schauen uns mal an...
...Konfig...
...ein...
...jetzt funktioniert's, okay...
...warum auch immer es vorher nicht funktioniert hat...
...GigaJet, JetBrains...
...Modules...
...Trust...
...Download Pre-Build Binary Indexes...
...ja ja, mach mal...
...ich weiß nicht was ich mir sagen will, aber...
...Pre-Build Binary Indexes...
...so jetzt müssen wir mal umstellen, dass es gut aussieht...
...ehm...
...wo war...
...in den JetBrains IDEs...
...das neue UI?
...wo hat sich das versteckt?
Oder war das nur in Rider?
Gibt's das nur für Rider? Gibt's das nicht für die anderen auch?
...Appearance...
...ah hier...
...New UI Enabled...
...Exit...
...sieht gleich...
...deutlich besser aussehen und moderner...
...jawoll, wunderbar...
...sehr schick...
...so, close...
...gut, okay...
...ich muss die Schrift glaube ich gleich noch ein bisschen größer machen...
...also wie soll so ein Module aussehen?
...Hello World Module...
...auf geht's...
...probieren wir das mal aus...
...zack...
...hab ich nicht richtig formatiert...
...oh nein...
...Style Guide Fail...
...okay, alles klar...
...geht schon mal gut los?
...wird das überhaupt gefunden?
...lull...
...ich geb jetzt mal was ein was es nicht gibt...
...okay, Unable to Load Module...
...also der findet das schon...
...schlechtes...
...Example...
...das kann natürlich auch sein, wir nehmen einfach...
...wir klauen uns einfach mal eines der Module...
...die schon drinnen eingebaut ist...
...Modules...
...wir nehmen einfach...
...den Timer...
...den es da drinnen schon gibt...
...klauen den uns mal raus...
...also ist ja recht übersichtlich...
...sollte es aber gehen...
...nö...
...has no attribute util...
...Python Errors, wer kennt sich aus Leute?
...geht schon gut los...
...ImportLib...
...has no attribute...
...util...
...das gucken wir jetzt auch mal bei dem Typ auf Github...
...das ist schon mal geil, wenn man die ersten Bugs beheben muss...
...bevor man überhaupt anfangen kann...
...einen Plugin zu bauen...
...was ist das für ein hübscher Prompt?
...du meinst das da oben?
...oder meinst du das?
...du meinst...
...das ist Starship...
...Chat-GPT-Fragen...
...ja...
...die Dot-Files lade ich...
...ich bin nicht eingeloggt in Github, sonst würde ich es hochladen...
...der Prompt ist tatsächlich ganz nice...
...das ist Starship...
...mit...
...habe ich da ein Alias für?
...mit dieser Config...
...und zwar habe ich als Grundlage genommen...
...Starship S...
...dieses Preset hier...
...M365 Princess...
...das habe ich als Grundlage genommen...
...nur...
...dass ich da einen 2 Zeilen Prompt daraus gemacht habe...
...anstatt einen 1 Zeilen Prompt...
...ich habe noch ein paar andere Sachen geändert...
...ich habe zum Beispiel...
...die Schriftfarbe auf Schwarz geändert...
...beziehungsweise nicht auf Schwarz...
...auf die Farbe von meinem Background...
...dass man es besser sieht...
...ich habe noch.NET hinzugefügt als Info...
...also wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt in den Repo hier geht...
...oder...
...Repo...
...also wenn man zum Beispiel in den.NET Projekt geht...
...dann siehst du jetzt hier zum Beispiel...
...gleich die Information die du brauchst...
...nämlich dass du im Master Branch bist...
...oh Leute...
...das Ding heißt noch Master Branch...
...sagt das bitte nicht auf Twitter...
...dass ich noch Master Branch verwende...
...sonst ist vorbei...
...sonst richtig dringert...
...also du siehst alle Informationen...
...auf einen Blick...
...und siehst dass du im Master Branch bist...
...wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde...
...git checkout...
...minus b keckel...
...man sieht auch jetzt bin ich nicht mehr ein Master...
...sondern ein keckel...
...jetzt gehen wir wieder zurück in den Master...
...jetzt bin ich wieder ein Master...
...löschen wir den Brandschmarr...
...so...
...das siehst du hier drinnen...
...und du siehst für.NET Projekte auch...
...was du für ein Target Framework hast...
...also.NET 7 in dem Fall...
...und du siehst was dein lokal installiert ist...
...ist dort nicht für eine Versionsnummer...
...find ich eigentlich ganz praktisch...
...aber jetzt sieht man auch schon den Grund...
... warum ich da einen zweizeiligen Prompt draus gemacht habe...
...guck dir den Prompt hier an...
...was willst du da noch schreiben...
...60% von meinem Bildschirm sind voll...
...dazu kommt rechts...
...die Uhrzeit...
...also 70% von meinem Bildschirm sind voll...
...was soll das...
...deswegen habe ich einen zweizeiligen Prompt...
...draus gemacht...
...weil ich es viel angenehmer finde...
...wenn die Stelle an der man schreibt...
...im Prompt immer an der gleichen Stelle ist...
...und nicht irgendwie mal hier...
...oder mal hier...
...oder sonst wie...
...ja deswegen habe ich da einen...
...zweizeiligen Prompt draus gemacht...
...und wie gesagt...
...ich habe im Prinzip nur die Farbe geändert...
...ein bisschen...
...zweizeiligen Prompt draus gemacht und.NET hinzugefügt...
...das war es...
...glaube ich schon...
...mehr oder weniger...
...ja also das ist ein custom Starship Prompt...
...ich lade die Files alle hoch...
...ich habe die Dinger hier alle in einem...
...in einem.file Manager...
...hat mir jemand im Chat empfohlen...
...finde ich wirklich ganz nice das Ding...
...was du mit Python Force machst, mach mal Ausrufezeichen heute...
...da hat...
...Fivehead Modge...
...eine schnell Zusammenfassung...
...reingeschrieben...
...also das funktioniert schon immer net...
...warum geht denn das nicht...
...warum kann man das nicht importieren...
...ich will mir den Widget für meine Statusleiste machen...
...das habe ich schon eine Weile vor...
...aber warum funktioniert das nicht...
...ne heute stimmt nicht...
...nicht so ganz...
...ImportLib has no attribute...
...ok man findet schon mal ein Issue...
...aha...
...ImportLib...
...has no attribute...
...so so...
...this is a problem...
...with a Python version used...
...if you...
...ong og...
Okay, es soll angeblich seit zwei Jahren schon funktionieren, macht's aber nicht.
Dann müssen wir doch mal Stack Overflow fragen, was die dazu sagen.
Hier, Stack Overflow weiß wieder mal Bescheid.
Beste.
Er leuchte uns Stack Overflow.
Nee, das hat damit nichts zu tun.
Stack Overflow, erklär uns, woran es liegt.
Ah ja, alles klar, excellent.
You need to do import importlib.util.
Ist das vielleicht ein Bug bei ihm?
Okay.
Alles klar, gucken wir mal, CD, User, nee, wo liegt denn der Kram?
CD, User, Share, Bumblebee, Status, Bumblebee, Bumblebee, Bumblebee, Bumblebee, Bumblebee,
und da kleppen wir jetzt mal nach importlib.
Importlib, Lul.
Vielleicht müssen wir erst noch fixen.
Hier, Module, import importlib, okay, das ist verbugged.
Machen wir gleich nachher ein Pullgequest auf, wahrscheinlich ist das verbugged, guck
mal.
Der sagt nämlich hier import importlib und Stack Overflow sagt, und wir wissen ja, dass
prinzipiell Stack Overflow bei sowas immer recht hat.
Stack Overflow sagt, man soll nicht import importlib machen, sondern import importlib
utils.
Warum?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich hab da keine Ahnung von, aber ich mach das jetzt einfach mal, mal
gucken, was funktioniert.
Geht einfach, geht einfach, Stack Overflow, Leute, okay, Chat, GPT, Chat, GPT, und, äh,
difference between, and, and importlib, okay, Chat, GPT, erklär uns, was, was ist der Unterschied
dazwischen, please?
Guck, ihr seht auch, dass das funktioniert hier oben, oh nee, doch, guck, funktioniert,
so halbwegs, so, fa, fast, doch nee, es funktioniert, ja, ehrlich gesagt, jede zweite Anfrage an
Chat, GPT ist eh überlastet und funktioniert nicht richtig, Prager, großer AI, AI Master,
Chat, GPT weiß es wahrscheinlich nicht, Chat, GPT, erleuchte uns, was, was ist es denn?
Es hat keinen Bock, okay, dann fragen wir mal, fragen wir mal GitHub, GitHub CodePilot,
dafür bezahle ich Geld, okay, CodePilot weiß es auch nicht, bleibt, bleibt uns eigentlich
nur übrig, solange Chat, GPT zu spammen, bis es antwortet, welches Chat, GPT Frontend
ist das, das ist Kommandozeilen, Rapper, was unter, was im Hintergrund einen Browser aufmacht
und Anfragen an Chat, GPT schickt, okay, Leute, wir werden es nie erfahren, was der Unterschied
ist, Chat, GPT weiß es nicht, und wenn Chat, GPT es nicht weiß, weiß es niemand, sind
wir uns einig, okay, weiter gehts, also, ich schmeiß jetzt hier erstmal ein paar Sachen
raus, weil ich keine Ahnung hab, was das macht, Settings, jetzt müssen wir erstmal ordentlich
Font einstellen, Font, Appearance, oder Font, JetBrains Mono, nein, Heck, Schriftgröße
18, ja, das ist doch schön, jetzt erkennt man was, aber das Farbschema gefällt mir
irgendwie nicht, ist so dunkel, oder, Leute, finde ich auch, dass es ein bisschen wenig
Kontrast ist zwischen dem Text und dem Hintergrund, was haben wir denn, was haben wir denn hier
zur Auswahl, Dark, Light, aber es gibt keine, es gibt keine Vorschau, wobei doch, es gibt
doch so ein Theme-Preview hier, Boah, Boah, Bonkers, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah,
boah, grad noch mal gerettet, High Controls,lengthbau, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, high contrast,
Dracula, da muss ich sagen, finde ich Dracula fast noch ein bisschen besser, fast ein bisschen
besser lesbar, boah немm es ist ja eine normale, OK, Dracula, ist es jetzt, Dracula, sag mal,
Sag mal, was ist mit Chat-GPT los?
Hat es keinen Bock?
Ich benutze das JetBrains Copilot-Theme.
Ok, wisst ihr was?
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Du verwendest was?
Copilot?
Das da?
Guck mir mal ein paar Bilder an.
Ok, es muss natürlich in Chrome aufgehen, es kann jetzt nicht einfach in Firefox da
drüben aufgehen oder so, ne?
Ok, die Seite ist nicht zum Zoomen gedacht.
Eigentlich ganz hübsch, ja.
Kann ich nicht einfach mal ein Rider-Theme verwenden?
Doch, ein gutes.
Rider-UI-Pack install, dann sieht es aus, dann sieht es aus wie Rider, wenn gut ist.
Rider Dark.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Rider Dark, ReSharper Dark, Visual Studio Dark.
Ja, wo ist denn der Unterschied dazwischen?
Ah, Rider Dark, fertig, lassen wir jetzt so.
Ok, so ich schmeiße jetzt hier mal ein paar Sachen raus, weil ich eh keine Ahnung, was
der Typ macht und wir das selbst machen wollen.
Ich wollte jetzt bloß wissen, wie ein Modul aussieht.
Also, so in it, bla bla bla, bla bla bla, bla bla bla, bla bla bla, ok, das, wow,
das lasse ich mal, weil ich nicht genau weiß, wie das sonst funktioniert.
Remaining time, brauchen wir nicht, Text brauchen wir nicht, Update, pass, wenn man will, dass
es leer bleibt.
Return, keckel, notify, pass, timer, play, post, ja, das können wir mal lassen, pass,
timer, reset, pass, state, return, nix, so, hier ist unser neues Widget.
Massive, das kann nix außer keckel anzeigen, was schon mal besser ist als die meisten anderen
Widgets auf dieser Welt, weil die meisten Widgets können nicht keckel anzeigen.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Make Function Static, nervt mich rum.
Für was lernst du Python, um es zu lernen, damit ich es kann, damit ich ein bisschen
mich besser auskenne, damit ist ganz einfach.
Hat es JetGPT jetzt eigentlich, Alter, wo ist das Problem, warum funktioniert das jetzt
gerade nicht?
Ok, Antwort von JetGPT, ImportLib ist ein Python-Modul für Dynamic-Modul-Loading, ImportLib-Util
ist ein Sub-Modul, das zusätzliche Utility Functions für Modularbeiten bietet, ok,
also aus irgendwelchen Gründen muss man ImportLib.Utils machen und gut ist.
Scheiß auf JetGPT, funktioniert gerade nicht.
Ok, also wie, also irgendwie gefällt mir das Farbschema auch hier drinnen nicht, vielleicht
soll ich mal neu starten, dann lädt das, vielleicht hat es nicht richtig geladen.
White themes gehören verboten, ja, schon, aber so schlimm sieht es doch gar nicht aus.
Ok, also, wenn, kann ich das jetzt reformaten, also sprich, wenn ich links da drauf klicke
auf mein Widget, dann wird TimerPlayPause aufgerufen, wenn ich rechts auf mein Widget klicke, zumindest
verstehe ich das so, dann wird TimerReset aufgerufen, so und ich vermute mal jede Sekunde
oder jede halbe Sekunde oder wie auch immer ich den Intervall eingestellt habe wird Update
aufgerufen und Text ist das was angezeigt wird.
Wir können jetzt, wir können ja mal testen ob das funktioniert, es geht jetzt ja schon
mal gut los, ich habe beispielsweise keine Ahnung, aus dem Kopf, wie man in Paisen private,
also private Members, Klassenvariablen macht, ich wage mich daran zu erinnern, dass das
eigentlich gar nicht geht, sondern dass alles irgendwie public ist, sondern man ein Minus
Minus davor macht und ein Underscore Underscore davor macht, um so zu tun als wären sie private.
Ich glaube irgendwie so war das, es ist, wenn wir Glück haben hält sich halt vielleicht
die Idee dran, so dass ich zumindest das nicht angezeigt bekomme dann, also gucken wir, gucken
wir doch mal, also ok, wir testen einfach mal was, wie macht man das jetzt, hier, macht
man jetzt, macht man jetzt, ok, jetzt geht es los, objektorientierter Stels in Paisen,
also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich nicht einfach sagen kann, blub gleich eins, ok,
das gibt zumindest schon mal kein Fehler, blub, this, blub, nee self ist es, gell, self,
wie so geht es, ja Moment, ist das jetzt, die Frage ist, ist das hier jetzt Static,
also eine Variable für alle Instanzen dieser Klasse oder ist das pro Instanz, in dem Fall
ist es egal, weil es nur einmal gestartet wird, aber wahrscheinlich ist das so verkehrt würde
ich jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch raus sagen, ach self muss man, ach Moment, das sind zwei
verschiedene Paar Schuhe hier oder wie, ach so das und das ist nicht das gleiche, ah verstehe,
also würde ich jetzt, ok, das heißt ich würde sowas hier machen, underscore, underscore,
sagen wir hier blub gleich eins, so und jetzt machen wir mal update, update ist self, ok
auto complete plus gleich eins, ich glaube plus plus ging nicht, gell, oder, doch nee,
geht nicht, plus gleich eins und hier sagen wir jetzt einfach return, self blub, ja, ok,
das funzt, wenn ich drauf klicke update ist schneller, weil bei jedem klick refreshed
wird, ok, so können wir schon mal Sachen in unserer Widget malen, wir haben ja schon
fast einen Countdown, wir haben ja schon fast einen Countdown, gut, dann habe ich jetzt
prinzipiell schon mal gecheckt, was da passiert, alles klar, gut, wie machen wir am besten
jetzt einen Timer, nutzt du auch Chat-GPT, um damit zu lernen, nee, nicht wirklich, ich
habe das hier eher für den Meme-Faktor, obwohl es noch nicht mal funktioniert gerade, ist
ja das allerschlimmste, ist irgendwie gerade kaputt, ok, also lasst mal überlegen, was
brauchen wir denn als private, als Variable, wir brauchen sowas wie ein, also was ich anzeigen
möchte ist folgendes, vielleicht fangen wir erstmal mit dem User-Input an, zwar was
ich anzeigen will ist folgendes, und zwar, hier, ich will sowas hier anzeigen, also sagen
wir mal so, hier, keine Ahnung, eine Minute und 15 Sekunden, und wenn ich da drauf klicke
will ich, dass es einen Countdown gibt bis Null und dann soll es rot werden und den Notification
anzeigen, ja, also total simpel im Prinzip, ja, nur dass ich es mit der Maus, ich will
es mit dem Mausrad so einstellen können, also mehr Timer drauf und so, also ich will jetzt
mit dem Mausrad hier scrollen können und dann sollen es zum Beispiel 25 Sekunden sein,
ich vermute mal, dass es ähnlich geht wie hier mit dem Mausrad, mit GUI, doch, siehst
du doch, die ganze Leiste ist damit gebastelt, wie der das unter der Haube macht, keine Ahnung,
also das ist ja eine i3 Status-Leiste, die GUI kommt ja nicht direkt aus Python, das
generiert irgendeinen JSON und i3 macht da draus seine Statuszeile, so, also, wie würde
ich denn jetzt mit dem Mausrad, da müssen wir mal kurz in den Source-Code von dem Kerl
gucken, wo könnte denn das sein, Core wahrscheinlich, decorators, event, input, input klingt schon
mal gut, left-Maus, middle-Maus, right-Maus, wheel-up, wheel-down, ok, wheel-up, wheel-up
und wheel-down, dann machen wir sowas wie hier Timer, Ink und Timer, soll ich Timer
plus nennen, plus, ey, komm, wir nennen es Timer Ink, Timer Deck, Deck, nee, so nennen
wir das, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt die Maus scrolle, müssen wir jetzt mal testen, ob das
funktioniert, wenn ich jetzt die Maus scrolle, dann sollte er normalerweise, was, Increment
plus eins, Dickel minus eins, gut, also Maus scrollen, funktioniert nicht, nice, Porgas,
warum nicht, wo ist das Problem, achso, weil ich return, immer statische Zeit, null, muss
return self blub machen, ok, besser, ok, ey, guck mal, verpiss dich, forever workstation,
ok, Increment geht, runter geht aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht, du hast die Zeile doppelt, 24
25, achso, ja, das sollte nicht, ups, das sollte nicht so sein, beim Update mache ich
immer plus eins, aber hier oben mache ich minus eins, also das sollte doch funktionieren,
gut, das Update können wir jetzt gerade mal rausschmeißen, das ist egal, achja, ok, achja,
es hat bei jedem scrollen geupdatet und hat immer wieder plus eins draufgezählt, deswegen
ist gar nichts passiert, ah, ja logisch, ok, jetzt kann ich mit der Maustaste, mit dem
Mausrad, mit dem Mausrad mehr und mit dem Mausrad runter weniger, das ist doch schon
mal schön, jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, dass wir dann ordentlichen Timer draus kriegen,
ok, also, wir brauchen sinngemäß sowas wie self, wir brauchen nicht blub, sondern wir
brauchen sowas wie Minutes und wir brauchen sowas wie Seconds, weil das will ich unterschiedlich
voneinander scrollen können, ok, der Python Way ist das auszuschreiben, also nennen wir
das Timer increment, schreibt man das überhaupt so das Wort, dekrementieren Leute, wenn ihr
mal schlau sein wollt, ihr dekrementiert jetzt den Wert, ja, dann machen wir das so, wenn
das Python Forum das das sagt, dann, oh, an die blub gibt es ja nicht, da kann man da
auch nichts dagegen machen, also wir haben, wir haben Minutes und Seconds brauchen wir,
dann brauchen wir noch irgendwie sowas wie, ich nenne es mal Selected, also mir schwebt,
mir schwebt Folgendes vor, ich will dort oben anzeigen, also Folgendes, ich will da
oben anzeigen, zum Beispiel 1 Minute 15 und jetzt will ich ja mit dem Mausrad die Sekunden
oder die Minuten erhöhen können, standardmäßig, wenn ich scrolle, weiß der ja nicht, was
ich scrolle, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir können das einfach umschalten mit der
rechten Maustaste, dass wir umschalten können zwischen Sätze Minuten und Sätze Sekunden,
das heißt ich brauche jetzt irgendwie sowas wie Selected, standardmäßig Sekunden, warum
nennst du die Variablen underscore underscore, weil es anscheinend der Python Way ist, um
Variablen private zu machen, ich meine warum hast du underscores in deinem Username, bestimmt
dass es mehr private ist auf Twitch oder mit Python Time Delta den Zeitwert verändern,
ist Time Delta sowas wie Time Span in.NET, vielleicht auch mehrere Timer zur Auswahl,
ja, mal gucken, mal gucken, ich guck mal, ich mein, ich könnte es ja mal auftreiben,
was hat er jetzt schon wieder verschmerzen, reform and file, ahja, das war nicht der
Python Way, wie man das gemacht haben, so, wieso überhaupt private, weil alles was von
außen nicht verwendet wird private ist per Default, oder sein sollte, kann es keiner
von außen aufrufen, aber wenn schon, müssen wir das gleich richtig machen, so, okay, lass
mal überlegen, wie können wir das jetzt machen, wie, 5-Hat, 5-Hat-Time, also, gib mal, Timer
Reset, Timer Reset ist ja meine rechte Maustaste, also ich will das so mal, guck mal, wenn man
Minuten Selected hat, soll das so anzeigen, und wenn man Sekunden Selected hat, soll das
so anzeigen, und dann, dass man weiß, was aktiv ist, dann kann man mit dem Mausrad hoch
und runter scrollen, ich glaube, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, so, Timer Reset, das
heißt, wir müssen jetzt gucken, If Self Selected, also Selected ist auch ziemlich, wie soll
ich das Ding nennen, Gescheit, ich mein, Selected, Time Selected, Time Part Selected, also wirklich
Havard ist es ja nicht, ich nenne es jetzt mal Selected, okay, so, gleich, wir könnten
das auch mit irgendeinem Enum machen, ich weiß nicht, wie Enums in Python funktionieren,
so, also wenn Self, also wenn das, okay, mich irritiert schon mal, dass es Self und nicht
This ist, ehrlich gesagt, also wenn es Selected gleich gleich Sekunden ist, dann will ich
umswitchen auf Minuten, irgendwie müssen wir ja, müssen wir, nee, moment nicht Minutes,
Selected auf Minutes, und ich will die Ausgabe, nennen wir das mal Self Punkt Text, da die
Fall Text ist, eine Minute 30, so, okay, funktioniert noch, wenn das Ding ist, dann wollen wir, okay,
ich mach mal eine, Self, Text, Mensch, Text, gleich, nur mal so zum testen, 30, und Else
If, wenn das Minutes ist, nee, Stunden will ich nicht, Stunden brauch ich nicht, 99 reicht,
sonst wird das auch zu lang hier oben in der Leiste, ach, Elif, Elif, okay, ist Geschmackssache,
so, und das ist jetzt Seconds, und dann ist es so, nur von der Idee, ob es funktioniert,
funktioniert, jetzt kann man schon mal auswählen, wo man was umschalten will, das ist schon
mal ganz praktisch, Mausrad macht jetzt noch nichts, mein Mausrad, so, okay, alles klar,
und jetzt, jetzt muss ich den, jetzt muss ich quasi den gleichen Spaß hier noch mal
machen, beim, bei Musik das noch mal machen, ja, theoretisch, theoretisch muss ich das noch
mal machen, so, also, jetzt muss ich den ganzen Spaß hier noch mal machen, wenn das Sekunden
sind, dann, Self, Seconds, Plus, Gleich, Eins, wir machen jetzt noch keine Abfrage, irgendwie,
ob das Out of Range ist, und ansonsten mache ich die Minutes, Plus, Eins, okay, das müsste
ja von der Idee her schon mal eigentlich sinnvoll passen, oder, so, und jetzt sagen wir mal hier
Self, Text, und jetzt müssen wir das irgendwie gescheit formatieren, jetzt müssen wir das
mal gescheit formatieren, oh, da stehe ich jetzt auf dem Schlauch, das geht doch irgendwie
so, Format, Self, Seconds, nee, Self, Minutes, so, und jetzt weiß ich nicht, was ich da angeben
muss, gibt es hier irgendwie eine Hilfe im, warum hat denn, jetzt mal seriously, warum
hat denn die, warum hat PyCharm keine, keine Hilfe fürs Formatieren, das trifft Time, oder
wieder Kreml, oder String, warum hatten das keine Anzeige dafür, nee, anscheinend nicht,
also wie mache ich das jetzt, ich will, dass es immer zwei hat, ich will, dass es immer
zwei hat, immer zwei Stellen, also muss ich jetzt, Python, Int, Format, Digits, oder so
was, Display Number with Leading Heroes, korrekt, aha, exzellent, Stake Overflow war es jetzt
wieder, so, will ich das haben, ah ja, nein, wait a minute, fast, fast Leute, fast, fehlt
noch ein Punkt dazwischen, ok, gut, gut, gut, ah ja, gut, wir haben noch kein Auto-Frame-Check,
aber jetzt gehe ich auf Minuten, jetzt erhöht er die Minuten, jetzt gehe ich auf Sekunden
und erhöht die, das ist nice, das gefällt mir, das hat was, jetzt kann ich umschalten
zwischen Minuten erhöhen und Sekunden erhöhen, wobei das natürlich keinen Sinn ergibt,
wenn es größer, größer als 59 sein kann und das größer als, sagen wir 99 oder so,
das Format macht man eigentlich nicht mehr, ok, was macht man jetzt, also wie soll ich,
wie soll ich das gescheit, aber wie soll ich ein Format String machen und dem dann
sagen, dass er mir das mit führenden Nullen machen soll, aber das funktioniert so nicht,
wie es im Chat steht, ne, habe ich noch nicht, das funktioniert so nicht, Leute, das kann
ich euch sogar als Python-Noob sagen, dass es nicht funktionieren wird, guck, funktioniert
nicht, kann noch einen Doppelpunkt dazwischen machen, ne, guck, das funktioniert nicht,
jetzt muss ich dem, jetzt muss ich dem sagen, dass ich, dass ich führende Nullen formatieren
will, wie mache ich denn das jetzt, irgendwie so, 2D, ne, 0, 2D, siehste, das funktioniert
so nicht, aber kann man, Python-Format-String-Digits-Leading-0, ach, hinten dran macht man das, so, wahrscheinlich
mit einem, oder, ah, okay, das ist gut, gut zu wissen, das hätte ich so wahrscheinlich
gar nicht rausgelegt, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, das finde ich exzellent, Leute, richtig
Five Head Time, das finde ich schick, so, also, das passt so weit, würde ich sagen,
dann machen wir das gleich hier und, ne, Moment, Moment, das passt nicht, das ist auch Schwachsinn,
was ich hier erzähle, also, erstens ist die Anzeige verkehrt, so, die Anzeige ist Müll,
so, die Anzeige ist nämlich in dem Fall Minutes 1, Seconds 30, dann machen wir hier irgendwie
mal eine eigene Funktion, die heißt dann sowas wie, Def, Duration, und Duration ist quasi
das da, ne, wobei, das brauche ich an der Stelle ja gar nicht, Moment, Moment, ne, doch,
ist doch richtig, so, ist eigentlich alles okay, brauche ich doch nicht, könnte man hier
nicht Daytime verwenden, doch, das brauchen wir dann für den eigentlichen Timer, aber
im Prinzip funktioniert das eigentlich, im Prinzip funktioniert das eigentlich, okay,
so, dann müssen wir jetzt noch abfangen, if, also, wenn das, wenn das Sekunden sind,
macht man den Pilsen jetzt eigentlich und und oder end, was ist die coolere Variante,
wie heißt dieses Toolbar-Modul, das nennt sich Bumblebee-Status, ist jetzt für mich
eigentlich ein Aufhänger, da ich mal ein bisschen basteln kann damit, end, aber es geht beides,
oder, es würde auch so gehen, ne, ach ne, geht nicht, ach ja, das hätte ich jetzt gedacht,
dass man da beides machen kann, if, selectes, end, self, seconds, kleiner, 59, ja, guck,
jetzt kann ich nicht weitermachen bei 59, okay, das ist nice, das gleiche machen wir
hier unten, jetzt kopieren wir den ganzen Krempel mal hier rüber, nur, dass wir jetzt
den Minus 1 machen, Minus 1, so, und dann sagen wir nicht seconds, sondern minutes und
die minutes sollen kleiner 99 sein, glaub, das ist okay, so, so, also, oh, hab ich nicht
reloaded, ach, ne, hä, Moment, jetzt ist doch vollkommen der Schwachsinn, was ich hier mache,
ah, Leute, das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn, null, alter, end, minutes, so, Moment, das
passt doch hier überhaupt nicht, es muss, seconds, dürfen nicht kleiner null sein, oder
nicht, müssen die, nein, die müssten größer, so, müssten größer gleich null sein, oder
ne, größer gleich eins müssen die sein, oder größer null, geht wahrscheinlich nicht,
wir müssen größer null sein, wir ziehen ja hier was ab, wir ziehen ja hier was ab, so,
und das muss im Prinzip auch größer null sein, das heißt, ich kann jetzt zumindest
schon mal nicht ins negative runter, richtig, 00 ist das quasi das kleinste, was ich einstellen
kann, das ist okay, das ist gut so, so, und das heißt, mit den seconds haben wir das hier
auch, und das heißt, hier muss man einfach nur kleiner als 99 gucken, nicht 00, 99, so,
das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier maximal auf 59 und hier maximal auf 99, also das heißt,
der höchste, das höchste Timer-Setting sind quasi 1,5, 1,40, ja, 1,40, quasi das höchste,
das reicht aber auch ein Timer, also mir reicht das ein Timer von 1,40, größer gleich null
oder nicht soll doch auch null geben können, kanns geben, weil es ist, bei eins ist es
größer null und dann zieht er eins ab und dann ist es null und beim nächsten Mal nicht,
also ich kann nicht, ich kann auf null runter, aber nicht weiter, okay, das passt, das ist
gut, gefällt mir, das hat was, was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist, warum das hier manchmal
irgendwie rumspacke, guck mal, jetzt steht das noch einer auf 55 und jetzt sind es wieder
30, wenn ich da rüber switche, warum und wenn ich jetzt wieder eins hoch mache sind
es wieder 55 und hier ist jetzt wieder eins, ah, nee, hä, ich setze, ich setze das doch
alles, musst du das jetzt verstehen, wo ist das Problem, ich meine, wenn ich hier rüber
gehe, warum ist es jetzt wieder eins, habe ich da einen Mist unten, ah, weil das hardcoded
da unten drinne steht bei, nee, wobei, ja doch, das ist, weil ich das unten hardcoded
reingeschrieben habe, weil ich zu low IQ bin dafür, können wir nicht, doch, wir machen
da jetzt, wir machen da jetzt mal das bisschen lesbar, also wir machen doch sowas hier, def
duration, da machen wir nämlich gleich schon mal einen daytime draus, return, tja, das
heißt auch daytime, wenigstens mal was, was ich vom Namen her instinktiv finden würde,
so datetime und dann wahrscheinlich sowas wie now, nee, das natürlich nicht, das wäre
zu einfach, wenn es einfach nur datetime now wäre, das ist datetime, okay, time delta
ist sowas wie ein time span, duration, es ist ja auch eine duration, also eigentlich
will ich ein time delta haben, also das ist viel eher das, so und time delta und wie,
ach guck mal, days, seconds, minutes, okay, also minutes gleich self.minutes seconds gleich
self.seconds, ja okay, so jetzt haben wir einen time span oder ein time delta, so jetzt machen
wir automatisch noch mal was zum formatieren, das war format, nennt man sowas so, kein
Plan, so und wenn wir das formatieren, dann machen wir das hiermit, ne, return, ja, so
müsste es doch, so müsste es doch eigentlich funktionieren, wobei brauche ich das überhaupt,
macht das überhaupt, macht das, macht das nicht wirklich Sinn, ich meine ich brauche
das genau, ich brauche das genau an zwei Stellen, nämlich hier und hier, mit dem Unterschied
einmal sollen hier die, sollen hier die seconds, nee, die minutes underscore sign und einmal
sollen die seconds underscore sign, das war es eigentlich, easy, oh falsch rum, falsch
rum, Herr Quaid, falsch rum, das so rum, Leute das, ich muss sagen das funktioniert besser
als ich mir das vorgestellt habe, jetzt kann man einfach einen timer einstellen, ja, wenn
ich jetzt sage, hey ich brauche einen timer von 1.30, man wird sie wahrscheinlich nicht
so genau einstellen, man sagt dann hier keine Ahnung, fünf Minuten und gut und go, easy,
okay also, ich will mal sagen, das UI haben wir schon mal, jetzt müssen wir noch schauen,
wie wir das mit dem timer machen, ich glaube das dürfte wahrscheinlich die kompliziertere
Variante werden, also, mal kurz überlegen, wir haben ja also, wir haben minutes, seconds,
selected, text, was brauchen wir denn sonst noch, wir brauchen irgendwie sowas wie self
timer state, so das ist dann sowas wie stopped, running oder paused oder sowas, wie macht
man denn enums und wie macht man jetzt so viel, wie macht man denn type annotations, das ist
jetzt ja auch was neues, aber ich muss erstmal gucken, Python enum, enum support, okay pog,
so, so passt, import, enum, hey funktioniert, so hat man dafür jetzt, hat man dafür jetzt
autocomplete, self, timer state, ne, dafür kriegt man kein autocomplete, das ist ja doof,
da hätte ich jetzt pycharm ein bisschen schlauer eingeschätzt, wie mache ich denn denn enum,
kann ich sowas hier machen, als wir irgendwie, timer state, und jetzt, ne, da kriegt man
kein autocomplete für, das ist schon blöd, aber man muss da ne klasse zuzumachen, dass
das mit dem autocomplete ordentlich funktioniert, das ist schon blöd, aber könnte ich jetzt
zum beispiel, okay, sag mal mal, sag mal ich hab ne, ich hab ne method, also, und da will
ich jetzt ne type annotation machen, und ich will, dass der, genau, das, ja, dass das da,
oder, nennen wir es mal, null, so, null soll vom typ timer state sein, wie geb ich das
jetzt an, geb ich dann so an, timer state, oder, ach ne, doppelpunkt, timer state, so,
too many blank lines, ja, ja, formatiere mein fall mal neu, wer sag ich, null, aber es gibt
kein autocomplete dafür, es gibt kein autocomplete, das ist natürlich, also kein autocomplete
für die states, das ist natürlich blöd, das heißt, man muss ne klasse machen, kann
man ne klasse inline machen, also kann ich sowas hier machen wie, timer state, jetzt,
null, aha, okay, also ist das nicht schlecht, okay, timer state, alles klar, ich will aber
keinen normalen enum, ich will eigentlich so nen binary, flag enum, weißte, flag enum,
gibt's doch bestimmt auch, enum, flag, flag, flag, okay, auto, jetzt wird's aber advanced,
hi iq shit, guck mal hier, import enum, flag und auto, also wir haben states, stopped, paused
und running für unseren timer, okay nice, das gefällt mir, das finde ich gut, kompiliert
das jetzt, ne natürlich nicht, das geht noch, das geht noch, okay, es ist noch nicht broken,
das heißt auch, ich kann jetzt quasi sowas hier anlegen, self, timer state gleich, timer,
warum gibt's das hier drinnen jetzt net, ach jetzt geht das oder wie, warum hat's das autocomplete
nicht gecheckt, nope, und warum geht das jetzt nicht, weil unresolved reference, da ist er
doch, hä, moment, ich kann, ich kann das hier als type annotation verwenden, aber hier kann,
was, das ergibt, das versteht, das ergibt keinen Sinn, self, nee, self kann das doch
nicht sein, das geht, das ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig, also das ist irgendwie komisch,
aber gut, mein, solange das funktioniert, jetzt kann ich auch quasi sagen, self, timer state,
okay, das ist ja auch okay, da kann ich auch mitleben, was schreibe ich da halt self, wobei
ich es halt nicht so genau checke, self ist ja eigentlich der, so der dispointer auf die
aktuelle instanz, warum geht self timer state, wahrscheinlich just python logik, also das,
das hätte ich verstanden, das geht auch, aber warum geht nicht einfach timer state, ich
mein, das ist doch definiert bei mir hier in der klasse, okay, es ist anscheinend einfach
so, ich glaub, das muss man nicht hinterfragen, ich, wahrscheinlich werden die ganzen pytonians
sagen, das ist ganz klar, dass das so ist, module ist eine klasse und kein namespace,
ja, das muss so sein, steht in der, steht im beispiel so drinne, die musik wird jetzt
richtig dramatisch, am moment ist der super mario galaxy ost, warum, aber ich, warum macht
youtube immer autoplay an zwischendurch, was soll das, mein wort, ich hab nie autoplay
an, okay, so, okay, jetzt brauchen wir sowas wie started at oder sowas mit, mit zeit drinne,
self started at gleich date time, date time, sagt der chat, und jetzt, oh, und jetzt geht
das, self, jetzt sollten wir noch sowas wie, ja, current, oh ne, ne, remaining oder sowas
oder okay, ist auch gut, und das wird jetzt ein date time, time delta wieder, ich hoffe,
ein time delta ist null, wenn man nix reinsteckt und nicht irgendwie, was weiß ich, irgendwas
merkwürdiges, wo man nicht mit rechnet, okay, das sieht doch jetzt schon nochmal relativ
sinnvoll aus, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt auf start drücke, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt auf
play drücke, high IQ chat, was mach ich dann, dann mach ich erstmal start, und start heißt,
ich sag self, timer, nee, nee, nee, nee, ich sag self, timer state, gleich, oh, das
ist ja, Leute, das ist ja eine Handhabung, richtig abartig, da kommt noch nicht mal ein
autocomplete Vorschlag, wenn ich hier, ne, das, also, das muss doch irgendwie anders
gehen, running, so, dann sag ich self, started at, date time now, also ab jetzt hab ich eingeschaltet,
nimm lieber Java, ja, genau, das geht natürlich an der Stelle auch, und ich glaub, pass auf,
als nächstes kommt nimm lieber C++, warum muss man da self davor angeben, das erschließt
sich mir nicht so ganz, aber, also, hier ist es, hier ist es, carbon, genau, rust, warum
nicht gleich, placing the fast written in rust, okay, und jetzt soll man, okay, self,
dann brauchen wir noch das aktuelle, und das aktuelle ist, okay, dann brauch ich doch das,
was ich hier oben angelegt hab, ja, siehst du, duration, also, wenn wir nämlich den timer
starten, dann ist die aktuelle Zeit die maximale, die maximale Zeit, weil wir starten ja den
timer erst, timer state außerhalb von, von der, ja, aber warum, warum kann ich in, kann
ich in, quasi ne, ne, ne, ne nested Klasse, warum muss ich die außerhalb von meiner anderen
Klasse machen, da ich drauf zugreifen kann, ich mein, die Logik erschließt sich mir nicht,
aber, ja, man könnt es ja mal außerhalb hinschreiben, was wird gebastelt, ein timer, für meine
Status, oh, ich hab mich für einen Sündungsfehler, für meine Status, so ne Art Stoppuhr für
meine Statusleiste, ja, hauptsächlich als Aufhänger, um mich mal mit, ein bisschen
mit Python gebastelt auseinanderzusetzen, so, also, timer state, haben wir hier oben
jetzt, okay, das heißt jetzt brauch ich wahrscheinlich auch kein Self an der Stelle mehr, ne, jetzt
funktioniert's, kann ich das auch wieder wegmachen, gut, so, also, wenn wir jetzt hier draufklicken,
dann soll er anfangen zu laufen, das heißt, wir müssen irgendwie hier drinnen, wahrscheinlich
in Update, würde ich jetzt, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten, in Update müssen wir jetzt
quasi sowas, müssen wir jetzt irgendwie Magic machen und gucken, wie viel Zeit verstrichen
ist, also, gucken wir mal, if self, timer state, Leute, ist, oder, oder, gleich, gleich,
was ist, the Python way, timer state, is running, also, wenn das, wenn das Ding funktioniert,
dann, gleich, gleich, warum jetzt gleich, gleich, was ist der Sinn davon, hier gleich,
gleich zu machen und hier ist, gerade bei einem I-Namen, also, der Chat sagt ja einheitlich
gleich, gleich, aber warum, jetzt ist es running, dann, aber is geht bestimmt auch, oder, also,
das ist der Unterschied zwischen is und gleich, gleich, so, self, was, also, okay, wir brauchen
jetzt erst mal date, time, date, date, date, time, kann man das nicht ein bisschen kürzer
machen, date, time, date, time, now, kann man nicht irgendwie sowas machen, wie, import,
date, time, from, date, time, date, time, is, date, time, oder so, so, from, date, time,
import, date, time, is, ey, das war doch gar nicht verkehrt, wie ich es geschrieben hab,
from, andersrum muss ich es machen, from, date, time, import, date, time, is, ja, das
ist doch auch gut, das ist gut, das ist viel, das ist viel schicker, aber kann ich jetzt
immer noch sagen, import, date, time, für den Rest, geht das jetzt noch, oder ist das
so broken, wenn ich das bei das mache, aber das macht man nicht so, oder, ich glaube,
so, wie wir es vorher hatten, war die, war die bessere Variante, nein, nein, du kennst,
doch, macht man das so, du hast doch alles drinne, naja, weil ich dann immer date, time,
date, time schreiben muss, das ist doch ziemlich bescheuert, ich mach das ja, wenn der Phipps
das macht, dann ist das wahrscheinlich weltweit anerkannte Standard, verstehe, okay, weiter
gehts, now, date, time, now, das brauchen wir, was müssen wir jetzt machen, jetzt müssen
wir gucken, jetzt, okay, Leute, jetzt, jetzt weiß ich was, wir müssen jetzt sagen, unser,
nee, Moment, wait a minute, was, was, jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, ich will jetzt gucken,
ob, started at, now, minus started at, kann man, geht das, dass ich quasi so was wie irgendwie,
delta, zwei Uhrzeiten voneinander abziehen, kommt da ein date, time, delta raus, ja, Menübar
tracking, DHL tracking, oh ja, das ist auch eine, das wäre auch eine coole Sache, okay,
delta, now, gut, delta, now, self text, ach, text haben wir, self text ist jetzt gleich,
machen wir mal delta und jetzt machen wir trill, weil das bestimmt noch nicht funktioniert,
es ist so eine Art Timer schon mal, da kann man nix sagen, das Timer schon mal, das ist
doch, das ist doch schon mal, prinzipiell geht das in die richtige Richtung, so, delta,
das müssen wir jetzt als nächstes machen, wir bräuchten noch einen Icon, ich meine,
das sieht kacke aus, das müssen wir, müssen wir irgendwie beschränken, also, wir müssen,
wir müssen irgendwo schon sagen, da schon was sinnvolles, was sinnvolles raus, wie formatiert
man das jetzt richtig, delta, format, nee, also wie war das jetzt, f, delta, aber gut,
wie sind, wie sind da die richtigen, die richtigen Abkürzungen für, ja, nee, das funktioniert
nicht, wie Format, ok, Python Format Time Delta, du kannst den String kürzen aus 2 nach
dem Komma, ach Punkt, Punkt 2, nee, das geht nicht, ok, Format Time Delta to String, exzellent,
Deck Overflow immer 5 Head, was ist das, wie gibt es kein Time Format für, Complete
Guide, genau, as far as I can tell, there is no built in math, warum scheitert es immer
an so einfachen Sachen, ansonsten ist die Standard Library doch wirklich ganz gut, warum
scheitert es an so simple Dinge, warum kann man kein Time, Leute, ich habe eine Idee,
wisst ihr was wir machen, pass mal auf, 6 Head, ich habe eine Idee, Python, how to get first
date time possible oder sowas, a date min, a date max, ok, pass mal auf, jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt kommt es, was Punkt, Doppelpunkt f im Leben nicht, im Leben nicht, der sagt ja
auch gerade, es gibt, nee, nee, falsche Syntax, du kannst aber Seconds auf dem Delta machen,
ich will ja nicht Seconds, ich will das als Minuten, Sekunden formatieren, wobei, Moment,
ja doch, ich will das als Minuten, ja Date Time to String, aber nicht Time Delta, aber
ich habe eine Idee, wir machen da einfach ein Date Time draus, guckt mal, wir können
doch einfach sagen, hier, wir haben noch Self, Self Current und das wird jetzt einfach gleich
Date Time, Date Time, nee, nur Date, nur Date vielleicht, min, nee, das gibt es doch nicht,
plus, plus Delta, und jetzt sollte, wenn das funktioniert, Date Time min, ja, jetzt habe
ich nämlich ein Date Time Objekt und jetzt kann ich da draus, Self Current Format, nee,
Moment, jetzt muss ich mich wieder dran gewöhnen, also wie geht das jetzt, so, Current, Doppelpunkt,
aber ich finde es immer noch doof, dass die Idee mir keine Completion, weil ich weiß
doch aus dem Kopf nicht die Formatdinger, Strip Time Python, was ich da brauche, gibt
es da irgendwie eine ordentliche Übersicht hier, also, was brauchen wir denn, wir brauchen
Minutes, m und wir brauchen Seconds, große S, ok, große M, große S, aber wie mache
ich das da jetzt, wie, so, nee, Moment, nee, nee, das ergibt so, das ergibt doch gar
keinen Sinn, was ich da jetzt mache, ich glaube in dem Fall sind Format Strings doof, oder,
dann ist es doch besser, ich mache das so, Prozent M, Prozent S, ok, da jetzt ein Doppelpunkt
dazwischen, ja, haha, guck mal wir haben einen Timer, progress, bloß ein Problem gibt es
noch mit meinem Timer, der Timer soll rückwärts zählen und nicht vorwärts, wobei sich das,
das lässt sich glaube ich relativ einfach fixen, ich ziehe, ich ziehe einfach Duration
davon ab, ich sag einfach Self Duration, Minus, Moment hast du die Gui gemacht, gar nicht,
das ist eine i3 Statusleiste, da kommt unter der Haube nur Jason raus, eine i3 Mal, guck
mal es funktioniert, es funzt, ich drücke auf Start und er zielt runter, jetzt mal gucken
ob das andere funktioniert, was ich mir überlegt habe, ich gehe mal auf Null, machen hier mal
keine Ahnung, zwei Sekunden, zack, oh, na gut das ist klar, dass das nicht funktionieren
kann an der Stelle, was war das Chat, habt ihr das auch gehört, der Error ist auffällig,
ok, du hast insofern recht, wenn ich einfach nur will, dass es rot wird bei Null, dann
ist das so gar nicht schlecht oder, dann geht es einfach kaputt und kackt ab, dafür muss
ich danach alles neu laden, dass es wieder funktioniert, ok, ok, weiter, Pfeiffer Time,
ich muss jetzt gucken, ob noch Zeit übrig ist, kann man in Python, also macht man sowas
hier, sowas wie isTimeLeft, return, self, größer, dateTime, timeDelta, ich hoffe mal
das geht einfach so, also wenn es größer Null ist, jetzt kann ich gucken, if isTimeLeft,
nee, self is, kann man das eigentlich auch so schreiben oder muss man self davor machen,
man muss self davor machen, ok, self isTimeLeft, wenn noch Zeit übrig ist, dann will ich das
so machen, ganz schön viel self, ja, einfach try exceptrum, ja, sixheadTime, genau, if
self isTimeLeft, else, self, text, also das finde ich in C Sharp ganz schön, da könnte
ich einfach so schreiben, da würde ich einfach so schreiben, guck, text, keckel, self, text,
gleich, ja, Null, Null, so, jetzt sollte es zumindest nicht mehr kaputt gehen, wir werden
das mal etwas runter machen, nämlich einfach auf eine Sekunde, fertig, easy, zum testen,
oh, was jetzt?
Das ist aber, das ist, das ist doch gar kein Daytime, das ist doch, das ist, hä, ach so,
ach so, ah, Moment mal, ich darf das hier nicht, ach so, ok, das ist ja blödsinnig,
ok, ich muss sagen, Delta, so, ok, und jetzt kann ich quasi so, sowas hier machen, ok,
dann, ok, ok, jetzt sollte es aber funktionieren, ok, jetzt geht es nicht mehr kaputt, jetzt
bleibt es bei Null hängen, das gefällt mir schon mal, jetzt muss ich gucken in Status,
wo ist Status, return, critical, dann müsste es rot werden, genau, critical, if, ich glaube,
das funktioniert mit inline, if, kann ich sagen, return, critical, if, self, time, nee, if,
not, time, self, time, left, geht nicht, else, nix, falsch rum, äh, hä, ok, ok, ok, ok,
habe ich irgendwie, ich will critical anzeigen, wenn keine Zeit mehr left ist, hä, wenn meine,
also, wenn meins größer ist als Null, dann ist noch Zeit übrig, warum ist das jetzt
verkehrt rum, also, ich meine, es funktioniert, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum, also, so funktioniert
es offensichtlich nicht, das heißt, das heißt, bei Null ist time left true, was aber überhaupt
nicht stimmt, weil sonst würde das hier oben ja nicht funktionieren, let's be, turn, critical,
ach, Moment, das ist, nee, doch, das verstehe ich nicht, warum ist das jetzt falsch rum,
ich meine, ok, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal is time left aus und gucken, was da drin steht,
ach nee, self, ja, was denn, false, das ist richtig, hä, ok, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt
blicke ich gar nicht mehr durch, true, false, ok, das hier ist false, was, so, what, das
ist doch falsch rum, ok, wir wissen das, in diesem Moment ist das hier, ah, Moment, nee,
ist doch, also, ich habe jetzt irgendwie gerade einen Knot im Kopf, warum geht denn das nicht,
es soll return critical machen, so, wenn das hier false ist, so, also, beziehungsweise,
wenn das, also, jetzt müsste es eigentlich, aber es macht vor, ach, das ist standardmäßig,
ach, so, ach, deswegen ist das rot, ach, so, ok, das funktioniert alles, duration muss
ich machen, ne, self, duration, ach, jetzt, ok, es war eigentlich alles richtig, es war
eigentlich, es war eigentlich alles richtig, ok, nice, gg eats, text, kaum macht man richtig,
dann funktioniert das auch, was soll ich den timer, ich soll den mal auf drei Sekunden
machen, ok, drei Sekunden, weil ihr seid chat, ok, bam, zack, zwei, eins und bom, funktioniert,
guck mal, jetzt, jetzt kriegst du ein Highlight, Highlight, das ist, jetzt muss ich natürlich
noch resetten können, aber ich kann schon mal wieder von vorne starten, vom Prinzip
her funktioniert das alles, was ich hier gebaut habe, was machst du in line 41 bis 44, das
ist, dass ich mitbekomme, wenn einer die Maustaste drückt da drauf, guck, wenn ich die linke
Maustaste drücke, ruft der timerplay-post auf, wenn ich die rechte Maustaste drücke,
dann stoppt er den timer und wenn ich das Mausrad bewege, dann, ja gut, das funktioniert
jetzt gerade noch nicht, aber wenn ich das Mausrad bewege, kann ich den timer hoch und
runter setzen, bis auf 99 Stunden und 59 Sekunden und das dauert jetzt halt, ach, das ist ein
ganz, so ganz, so ganz, wait a minute, ey funktioniert, ach so, das ist weil er dann,
ach, jetzt versteh ich's, weil es 60 Minuten und dann eine Stunde ist, ach, so, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ok, ok, dann stimmt der timer, ah, Moment, aber warum ist das so, warum ist
das ein Problem? Duration. Ach so, ja klar, ha, hier, dadurch ist das, kann man die Minuten
nicht, nicht komplett ans, nee, hm, nee, immer in der Stunde ist mir das zu lang, ich
mein das doch, ich mein man könnte auch, was ist es denn, ha, könnte man auch machen,
oha, kann man hat, über 90 ist, uh über 60 da muss man noch was überlegen, gut, doch
zumindest müssen wir zuerst mal gucken, was die grundsätzlichen Funktionen tun, timeline
minutes, also, das funktioniert aber nicht dann kann ich es nicht mal als daytime ordentlich
formatieren
ich mein ich könnte es ne minnits bringt ja auch nix time delta minnits ist ja nicht
ist ja nicht inzgegeben aus dem hat time delta gar keine minnits oder nö was der chat
wird er für dinger erzählen guck mal seconds days microseconds also ich muss
ehrlich sagen die standard library habe ich besser in erinnerung ich mein so
elementare sachen warum muss ich mir die selbst ausrechnen mein klar ich habe ich
habe seconds days microseconds ich kann mir auch minnits selbst ausrechnen aber
warum sollte ich das machen müssen total seconds total seconds ist das
interessante an der stelle weil seconds auch verflauen ja bei 59 quasi das ist
alles noch nicht so muss man sich glaube ich dran gewöhnen
ok jetzt muss ich mal gucken dass ich das resetten kann also mein es ist ja schön
und gut dass der timer ablaufen kann aber ich kann den timer noch nicht
resetten also muss ich jetzt quasi noch mal gucken wie ich das wie ich das
resette total seconds total seconds ist minnits vermute ich das mal stark halt
die gesamte zeit in sekunden und seconds ist halt nur quasi 0 bis 59
wie in pyson die packages funktionen ich habe keine ahnung
keine ahnung ich habe da keinen großen plan von wie gesagt ich ich prokramiere
timer minus eins das als kenne ich mich damit großartigen sachen aus mann also
was für pein was fast für pyson packages ganz gutes habe ich mitgekriegt
ist hip x das installiert er quasi ein package bzw. also nicht für libraries
sondern für für ausführbare programme ist das ganz praktisch weil der
installiert ihr alles was du brauchst inklusive abhängigkeiten in ein eigenes
verzeichnis hast du keine hast du keine konflikte weil wenn du pandas oder wenn
du irgendwie zeug installieren willst zum konvertieren also wenn du nicht als
libraries verwenden willst sondern als shell befehle dann ist pipp x ganz gut
habe ich festgestellt wenn du es natürlich als libraries will es keine
ahnung welche umgebung ist das den liegungs das hier das ist i3 wm aber der
rest des customer ist i3 ist eigentlich nur war dafür zuständig ist hier mehrere
fenster aufzumachen ich will jetzt noch mal gucken dass man ist dass man den
timer auch resetten kann heimer reset gut das also müssen wir gucken if self
state heimer state running wenn es running ist dann will ich pause machen
wie auch immer man hause macht ne will ich pause machen ja eigentlich eigentlich
will ich pause machen ich will pause ich will ich will ja eigentlich running
pause stopp wobei wir machen jetzt mal running wir machen jetzt hier stopp wir
machen hier stopp irgendwas anderes ist dann das da muss ich mir noch was
überlegen weil man das war hier return sein dass man es da unten so stehen
lassen können ist es ist running so dann will ich das ganze stoppen also heimer
state gleich heimer state stoppt man braucht es so groß und klein also das
heißt jetzt sollte es schon mal ausgehen wenn ich rechts klicke ok das ist ok
das funktioniert wenn ich rechts klicke
wenn ich rechts klicke bleibt stehen
haben wir mal ein bisschen was was länger immer 15 sekunden oder huppst
haben wir jetzt gemacht 15 sekunden
ob
und wenn ich jetzt wieder starte naja gut da geht es wieder 15
sekunden zurück alles klar ja ist auch logisch so aber ich kann es stoppen wenn
ich es stoppe will ich aber dass der timer zurück geht auf duration oder ja
da will ich dass es dass der timer zurück geht auf volle volle pulle
der state soll sich resetten
wie habe ich das genau so der reset sich automatisch oder habe ich das
gebaut ja der reset sich automatisch ist ja es ist ja dann wieder time left
und
der text ist quasi wieder das gleiche
war so was vielleicht brauche ich das vielleicht brauche ich das noch das
gibt an der stelle
selft duration so und
also datetime zeug fackt mich jetzt schon ab
was zum teuf ich will die standard library nicht editieren man glaube es
geht los lull ganz ganz bestimmt will ich dass
das standard library hinzufügen easy das das das kann auch nicht das kann auch
nicht der weißheits letzter schluss sein hier oder ein ordentliches datetime zu
formatieren das ist doch abartig
ist normal
eklig man muss man immer selbst davor schreiben das besteht ja wirklich fast
fast ok es gesettet sich es gesettet sich das ist schon mal gut also ich kann
jetzt ok ich gehe jetzt hier runter auf vier sekunden auf drei ok starten gut
bäbä bäbä alles klar wunderbar hier blink blink blink rechtsklick reset ok
nice das ist doch schon mal funktioniert damit kann ich auch schon was anfangen
das kann das ist doch schon mal ganz gut so wie es ist
so leute wir haben noch zehn minuten zeit da muss ich was fuddern machen wir
noch was sinnvolles wird die leiste per python gemordet exakt ich baue in meine
leiste den timer ein den ich selbst den ich mit mausrad stellen kann und der
dann der dann blinkt wenn er ready ist
ok lasst mal kurz was kann man das auf die stelle was kommen zehn minuten noch
sinnvolles sinnvolles einwand da da fehlen da fehlen noch ein paar sachen
daytime und auch time sind beides nicht so schön ja ich merke es gerade ich
hatte bisher eigentlich immer ziemlich guten eindruck von der pyson standard
standard lip aber ich muss sagen ehrlich gesagt die standard library ist das was
mich bei allen anderen sprachen außer sie schafft dort net immer nervt ich habe
gar keine großen schmerzen mit dass es anders funktioniert wie sagen wir mal
unter sie schaab aber da ist immer so einiges ich meine vieles in der dot net
standard library ist auch wir zum beispiel hast du dort zu viele daytime
klassen du hast dann daytime daytime offset time span times du hast da fünf
sechs verschiedene sachen da blickst du auch überhaupt nicht durch
bei rust rust ist die standard library auch nicht der wahnsinn für bei rust
brauchst du für jeden scheiß irgendwelche irgendwelche packages so
deswegen musste ja das besteht deswegen besteht ja jedes rust projekt irgendwie
aus 30 grades oder so als abend dependencies also das hat mich in go auch
genervt in go gab es auch so einige dinge wo ich mir gedacht habe warum ist das
nicht in der standard library ich kann euch jetzt leider kein beispiel sagen
fällt mir fällt mir gerade nicht ein aber gab immer mal wieder warum ist das
eigentlich nicht einfach in der stadt ich glaube datetime war auch so ein ding
was wobei ich glaube datetime war in go ganz ok
ja go developer sagen dass immer zu jetzt man findet die eigentlich die
lieblingssprache natürlich am besten
ja genau stimmt das war richtig das war richtig abartig mit diesem komischen mit
diesem komischen 23 49 59 und sowas wo ich erst nicht gecheckt habe dass das
kein beispiel ist sondern das 1 zu 1 zu heißen muss ja das ist ganz wir das ist
ganz wir ja so muss er das in go machen und wer jetzt denkt dass hier ist ein
beispiel nein nein nein nein du schreibst in go nicht ich hätte gerne hier das ja
hier den monat diese magic zahl bedeutet ich will das ja also in go ist es nicht
mit dollar und jetzt los dollar y dollar m das ist magic string genau genau also
das muss so sein in go das hier sind dass hier 15 sind die minuten und die
stunden 04 sind die minuten und 15 die sekunden das ist hier unten guck mal
hier schreibt er auch wieder 2006 hin ja dass das war richtig ppega das habe ich
am anfang überhaupt nicht gecheckt ich dachte immer das sind irgendwelche
beispiele und ich habe nie verstanden warum es bei mir also wisst ihr ich
habe das dann so ähnlich geschrieben und hat dann reingeschrieben 2023 oder 2000
oder ging das immer nicht ich habe gedacht hä warum muss dort überhaupt bei
format in datum rein format müsse das format und nicht der input das habe ich
erst mal überhaupt nicht gecheckt das habe ich nicht gecheckt ich glaube wenn
man sich dran gewöhnt hat ist es durch ist das ok ja man muss ich muss ich dran
gewöhnen ich weiß übrigens wieder was mich was mich ein bisschen gestört hat
in go tatsächlich in der stade in der stade library es ist auch wenn go
viel wert auf ja so paralleles ausführen und so was liegt ich mein das
ist im namen der sprache drinnen mit mit go routinen und allem muss ich sagen
ich war etwas
negativ überrascht im negativen sinne überrascht wie wenig die go standard
library bietet für multithreading und und synchronisierung und so was die
haben die haben glaube ich nur zwei sachen drinne die haben irgendwie den
lock haben lock lock group und er will lock oder so was
ja die haben irgendwie die haben irgendwie drei sachen
oder was im utx irgendwas da bin ich nicht so ganz mit klar gekommen
manchmal hätte ich mir noch ein bisschen bisschen mehr sachen noch gewünscht es
kann aber auch sein es kann aber auch sein dass ich es nicht richtig benutzt
habe das sollte man nicht immer ausschließen also lasst mal überlegen was
habe ich denn damals gemacht ich habe ok warte mal warte mal warte mal ich habe
mehrere streams gehabt von webcams und es doch hier nicht von webcams keine
gachi bus time von kameras nicht von webcams
so und ich hatte mehrere streams mehrere streams gespeichert und so genau ich
hatte so was in go ich zeigte euch mal kurz ich mir haben gleich 18 ich muss
ich hatte sinngemäß so was in go ich bin mir gerade nicht mehr sicher wie die
structs und tags in go ist ich hatte hier so was streams in go ist es ja irgendwie
umgedreht irgendwie stream stream muss man in go irgendwie so muss man das
machen so streams und und dieses dieses stream objekt das war von von der
library und jeder stream hatte quasi so eine eine irgendwie insert frame
nenne ich das jetzt mal also das hier das hier ist das das das stream objekt
sondern es hatte quasi in insert insert frame methode drin so und das problem war
jetzt ich habe multithreaded da reingeguckt in in diese stream stream
collection ich musste aber pro stream den lock haben das nicht parallel
reingeschrieben wurde weil sonst gab es probleme so und dann musste ich hier
irgendwie so was da muss ich bei jedem stream objekt wie so ein lock noch
dabeimachen es war es war es war eklig und an der stelle wusste ich auch nicht
wie ich hätte gescheit mit channel machen sollen ich kann mich noch dunkel
dran erinnert das hat mir nicht so gut gefallen
tommy dankeschön für den sub es kann sogar sein dass ich ich habe sogar den
reader writer lock glaube ich verwendet weil lesen lesen war vollkommen ok aber
schreiben durfte nur einer ich glaube das war sogar so und dann musste man
ich krieg es nicht mehr genau zusammen keine ahnung es war zumindest ein bisschen
ein bisschen eklig
so ich würde sagen wir machen es nächstes mal weiter ich gehe jetzt gleich
was fuddern
was hast du habe keine eins anwesenden für weil ich nicht wusste ob a gleich
in seriously deswegen gibt es keine eins das ist so ein ding das kann
funktionieren kann nicht funktionieren ehrlich gesagt 100 prozentig wüsste ich
auch nicht 100 prozentig wüsste ich auch nicht weil ich mir das durchaus
vorstellen kann
dass das funktioniert ich mein man würde normalerweise von ausgehen es
geht nicht weil es ist ein fließkomma zahl was
soll die damit machen allerdings ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
peißen einfach nur vor dem komma nimmt und es trotzdem funktioniert das ist
das ist implementierungsfall das muss man doch nicht aus dem kopf wissen
also probieren wir es mal aus also und einfach schreiben gucken ob es passt oder
nicht ja weil du es in der arbeit weil du in der arbeit einfach mal so notebook
mit interpreter hast um zu gucken ok das funktioniert nicht
das funktioniert nicht aber 44 geht das ist es hätte auch genauso gut umgedreht
sein könnte ich habe keine ahnung ich hätte auch keine ahnung gehabt
also muss man wahrscheinlich erst mal so was hier machen das funktioniert dann
wieder ok wie wie dem auch sei dass jetzt alle eins zu knüpfen da sieht man mal wie
bescheuert das ist vieles in der schule also in der normalen schule ist einfach
viel zu sehr auswendig gelerne who cares seriously es ist doch jetzt mal
ernsthaft jetzt mal ernsthaft selbst wir reden wir mal wirklich über irgendwie
professionelle anwendungsentwicklung jemand der tagtäglich peißen macht der
wird das wahrscheinlich wissen gehe ich mal von aus aber der muss das nicht
wissen das ist überhaupt nicht wichtig wichtig ist dass man dass man erkennt
ok das ist irgendwie merkwürdig das passt an der schildung und einfach
nachguckt aber dass man das alles im kopf weiß ist komplett unsinnig man
kann einfach googeln danach man kann es kurz in interpreter eingeben ausprobieren
also man sollte die leute doch nicht danach bewerten ob sie programmieren
können in dem sinn ob sie auswendig gelernt haben ob die typ konvertierung
richtig funktioniert
sondern ob er also ein bisschen logik dahinter checkt also ist also da wird
sehr viel wert auf auswendig lernen gesetzt
in der realität passt halt keiner passt halt so keiner float warum nicht also ich
kann dir sagen ich weiß nicht wie ich den python machen würde also ich kann
dir sagen wie ich dort net machen würde in dort nett würde ich sagen in punkt
try pass und gucken ob es funktioniert so an den pausen wirst du wahrscheinlich
sagen pass und try except rum oder so keine ahnung wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht
wie man es da gescheit macht
wir können beziehungsweise kannst du übung auch mal in discord bot jaka
übrigens wisst ihr was wir demnächst machen ich habe was richtig cooles
gefunden führen für ein stream gucken wir uns als nächstes an
ein richter erst mal auf da da nicht nicht hier wir suchen auf dac dac oder
set servers kennt das jemand bevor ich es aufmache
kennt ihr das
das ist das ist eine richtig richtig coole kräfte habe ich heute gefunden
zufällig zufällig er weiß ich glaube auf reddit oder so das ist quasi leet
code genau leet code für linux die sind sehr gut guckt da gibt es
aufgaben zum beispiel eine aufgabe welcher prozess schreibt in das log
file und ich soll raus bekommen welcher prozess das ist und dann der test ob ich
die aufgabe bestanden habe ist ein feind darauf zu machen und gucken ob es
älter als sechs sekunden ist und man bekommt echte linux kisten wo man sich
per ssh drauf verbinden kann und kann man kann dann die aufgaben machen mit
time limit das ist cool das werden wir demnächst mal im stream machen also die
einfachen sachen sehen wir wirklich simpel aus aber vielleicht sind die ja
mit ein bisschen vielleicht ist ja ein bisschen gebadet zum beispiel das beim
prompt steht willkommen bei ubuntu und es ist gar kein ubuntu sondern es ist ein
slackware oder denkst du erstmal ok wo ist der ganze scheiß hier
vielleicht wirst du ja gebadet in den tests keine ahnung das war gucken aber
die idee finde ich gut ja ok leute ich gehe auf wir sehen uns dann spätestens
morgen früh auf waren streben bis denn zu